What's up y'all? As always, welcome
wherever you may be watching. YouTube,
Facebook, Rumble. Got the YouTube
comments here. I guess Facebook comments
too. Uh, welcome everyone. JD, welcome.
Random T Chance 21st century Paul
inspired you to godliness or inspiring
you I guess non-conformist. Darien,
welcome everyone that is here. Um, glad
that you are here with us. Last week's
open mic went so well that I thought,
you know, um some things kind of fell
through and so I thought, what the heck,
let's just run it back and pick up where
we left off and do it again this week.
Um we got a little bit off topic during
some of the last discussions. Um there's
reasons why I don't want to do that. Not
because I don't like discussing certain
things, but um sometimes we're not able
to hit as deep as I'd like and we end up
getting off of topic anyways and then we
just spend a bunch of time on that. So,
I'm going to try and be a little bit
more diligent this time and really keep
us on track. Uh, because folks, the
Seventh Day Adventist Church is
proitizing a false Christ and a false
gospel. Neither of which can save a
person. If you are wrong on Christ, you
will be wrong on the gospel because the
gospel is Christ's gospel. Um, we want
Adventists to come know the truth. So,
we are willing to state the hard truths,
taking the arrows in our back in hopes
that God will use it to draw a people to
himself.
The link to join will be pinned in the
chat later. Um, please refrain from
joining unless you are a 7th Day
Adventist, please. This time is for
discussion with Seventh Day Adventist,
not just about any sort of theological
topic with any sort of individual. Um,
everyone else is free to engage in the
live chat. Please keep it uh friendly,
if you will. Moderators, please look out
for any sort of belligery and that sort
of thing and do your thing with that. I
will say though, there is actually quite
a bit of information to get to first.
So, I will try and get to as many people
as possible in the time frame. Rest
assured, this will not be the last one
of these. So, if we aren't able to bring
a ton of people on, I apologize. I don't
know how long it's going to take. Um,
but first, like I said, we do need to go
over a decent amount of stuff so that
it's documented. Um, well, I'll leave it
at that until we we get to that stuff.
Our first guest is actually going to be
here by way of screenshot since he
blocked me thinking it keeps me from
seeing what he says about me. Um, and so
we'll interact with those claims as I
think they'll be uh beneficial for the
audience. Uh, but before bringing that
up, just like last week, I need to lay
the foundation for why this platform,
this platform when I'm speaking here
holds to the position that we do on
these two topics for tonight. Uh, doing
a little bit of a comparison, if you
will, kind of like we did last week. I'm
going to dive a little bit deep here
because I want to expound upon what I
was saying last week, but give further
clarification to make it crystal clear
what the claim is um and the why really
behind it. Um so first I want to talk
about the gospel that this platform
upholds, affirms and seeks to proclaim
as well as the Jesus that we seek to
exalt and lift up. These are the two
foundational cardinal doctrines of the
Christian faith. If you are off on
these, you are not a Christian. Period.
So after we will look at a number of
sources from Adventist leaders,
theologians, authority figures, that
type thing, showing where the
differences lie. Um after that, like I
said, we will respond to an SDA who
fancied himself to spread some lies
about our platform online. And then
afterward, we will bring on uh the SDAs
that would like to join and discuss,
time permitting. So to start
this is the gospel that this platform
affirms, proclaims, believes and that is
the gospel of the kingdom.
So Luke 8:1 there are a plethora of
places that we could go to. Matthew,
excuse me, Matthew 24:14, Mark 1:15. Um,
but notice what it says. This is talking
about Jesus out doing his ministry with
the disciples. And he says, "Soon
afterward he went on through cities and
villages," this is talking about Christ,
"proclaiming and bringing the good news,
that's gospel, of the kingdom of God,
and the twel were with him." So the good
news or the gospel, we oftentimes just
use the term gospel for shortorthhand,
but it's really the gospel of the
kingdom of God. part of the gospel news,
the good news entails Jesus's kingdom
being established, which the Old
Testament in great length foretold of.
So, um, the the Messiah's kingdom, it
was the prophetic hope essentially of
the Old Testament, uh, if you will.
Isaiah 9 6-7, for example, is a
messianic prophecy about Jesus and his
kingdom. Here's Mark 1:15 as well and
saying, "The time is fulfilled and the
kingdom of God is at hand. Repent and
believe in the gospel." So, the gospel
has to do with Christ's kingdom. And
again, the prophecy in Isaiah, which it
should have had verse seven here. So,
I'm going to add that because ah, look,
it got added right there. Bunk. Easy
fix.
Okay, let's run this back. Try it again.
There we go. So, what is the prophecy?
Notice what it says. For us, a child is
born, prophesying about Christ. To us a
son is given and the government shall be
upon his shoulder. And his name shall be
called wonderful counselor, mighty God,
everlasting father. That's not a title
of the God the father, by the way,
folks. That is a term of uh just like
Satan's called the father of lies. Um
that doesn't mean that he's God the
father of lies or something like that.
It's that Christ is essentially the
father of time, the creator of time,
prince of peace. of the increase of his
government and of peace. There will be
no end on the throne of David and over
his kingdom to establish it and uphold
it with justice and with righteousness
from the time forth
and forever more the zeal of the Lord of
hosts will do this. So Isaiah prophesied
that when the Messiah would come, his
kingdom would be established, his
rulership would know no ends, and he'd
rule forever more. this is happening
presently, which is what Hebrews 10:1
through13 and elsewhere tells us. We've
looked at this uh I don't know how many
times on the channel, but just to look
at it again. Um, and it didn't get added
on here. That's fine. I'll just read it
to you. You guys can look it up if you
want. Hebrews 10 11 through13 says, "And
every priest stands daily at his service
offering repeatedly the same sacrifices
which can never take away sins. But when
Christ had offered for all time a single
sacrifice for sins, he sat down at the
right hand of God, waiting from that
time until his enemies should be made a
foottool for his feet. So the author
makes a marketked contrast between the
Levitical priesthood and the Mkisedcian
one. The Levitical priests always stood,
they were working because the work was
never finished. But Jesus on the other
hand being after the order of Mkisedc is
not standing. He is seated and he is
ruling and reigning as all of his
enemies are being made his foottool.
This is because he isn't only a priest
but a king which is what Hebrews 7:1
tells us. It tells us that MelkiseDC
wasn't only a priest but he was a king a
king of Salem. So Jesus is ruling as a
king mediating for his people as a
priest king while all of his enemies are
being made a foottool ruling over all of
heaven and earth with all authority. So
this is what that was prophesied in the
Old Testament. That's what the author of
Hebrews is actually quoting from here in
in Hebrews 10 when he talks about all of
Christ's enemies being made a foottool.
The psalter, that's what he's quoting
from. Psalm 110 uh 1-7, which is
actually the most quoted psalm in all of
the New Testament. But it is a messianic
prophecy about the Messiah and his reign
as a king over his kingdom. So notice
what all is prophesied in this.
So he says, 'The Lord says to my Lord,
an interesting phrase there that we
could go really deep on as well, "Sit at
my right hand until I make your enemies
your foottool.
The Lord sends forth from Zion your
mighty scepter. Rule in the midst of
your enemies. Your people will offer
themselves freely on the day of your
power in holy garments from the womb of
the morning. The dw of your youth will
be yours. The Lord has sworn and will
not change his mind. You are a priest
forever after the order of MelkiseDC.
The Lord is at your right hand. He will
shatter kings on the day of his wrath.
He will execute judgment among the
nations, filling them with corpses. He
will shatter chiefs over the wide earth.
He will drink from the brook by the way.
Therefore, he will lift up his head. So,
it was prophesied that when the Messiah
comes, he would establish his kingdom
after the order of MelkiseDC forever,
ruling and reigning as a priest king.
Hebrews tells us that this is what Jesus
is doing right now. So after his
ascension, he approached the father
presenting his sac his his single
sacrifice and he sat down on his throne
where he now rules and reigns having
accomplished redemption. This is good
news because death, sin, Satan and the
grave have been defeated. So the
government powers of the world are
subject to Jesus Christ as king. He has
the keys to death and hell. He will one
day throw wickedness out of his kingdom,
including all of his enemies. Remove the
curse off the creation to rule and reign
forever with his people with all
wickedness gone. This is absolutely or
uh this is actually why sin won't enter
in again by the way. Um if you continue
reading and I think I do actually have
this one brought up actually there's
where Hebrews 10 is and was supposed to
be earlier as well as Hebrews 7:1. But
if you keep reading in Hebrews chapter
12 25- 29 for those that would like to
follow along. It tells us um of this
kingdom that is in view here and that it
is unshakable. Which is speaking about
sin coming in and and shaking and how
that's not going to be able to happen in
um Christ's kingdom. So notice what it
says. Says, "See to it that you do not
refuse him who is speaking. For if they
did not escape when they refused him who
warned them on earth, much much less
will we escape if we reject him who
warns from heaven." At that time his
voice shook the earth. But now he has
promised yet once more I will shake not
only the earth but also the heavens.
This phrase yet once more he's quoting
from the Old Testament here indicates
the removal of things that are shaken
that is things that have been made in
order that the things that cannot be
shaken may remain. Therefore let us be
grateful for receiving a kingdom that
cannot be shaken. And thus let us offer
to God acceptable worship with reverence
and awe. For our God is a consuming
fire. So the prior verses compared the
earthly scene at Si to the heavenly
scene of the better mountain, Mount
Zion. And the author invokes the way God
spoke when he gave the old covenant at
Si. Um and Psalm 68:8 states that the
ground shook at God's words. So when he
says yet once more, he is quoting like I
said from the Old Testament there. He's
quoting from uh Hagi 2:6 where God tells
of a prophecy of the new creation
ironically revelation 21:1. So it
continues with the same theme of the
whole letter and that's that God will
replace something temporary with
something eternal. So just as the old
covenant was was replaced by the new,
the old creation is replaced by the new
and the new creation is a kingdom that
cannot be shaken. So meaning no
corruption, destruction or sin can enter
this kingdom because Christ is ruling
and reigning. So remember that because
that's actually going to become
important in uh a little bit with
something else that we look at. But
Christ's gospel is about salvation,
redemption, reconciliation,
righteousness, etc. All of this comes by
the person and work of Jesus Christ on
behalf of sinners. And all that turn to
him in faith, accepting his gospel
message will find peace with God.
Because as the apostle preached at the
Aropagus in Acts 17, repent and believe
the gospel because there is coming a day
in which God is going to judge the world
in righteousness. And unless you are
found in Christ, it is going to be a bad
day for you. So turn and live. Be united
to your maker and experience all the
benefits that come with that.
Forgiveness of sins, adoption, becoming
a child of God, being made a new
creature in Christ, being transferred
from the kingdom of darkness into the
kingdom of light, Christ's kingdom, uh,
and so on. There's I'm sure there's more
that I'm I'm just off the top of my
head. So, summarized using scriptural
landmarks, the message is this.
Man is a sinner.
Our sin has separated us from our maker.
In his grace, God entered into his own
creation in the person of Jesus Christ,
born of a virgin, and lived a perfect
and sinless life, fulfilling all the
laws demands on a mission by God the
Father to save sinners from
condemnation.
He paid the penalty for sin, which is
death. And he bore the sins of his
people in his body on a cross, making
propitiation by his blood. He died, was
buried, and resurrected in the same body
he died in on the third day for our
justification. By a living faith in the
person and work of Jesus, God graciously
declares a person righteous. They are
reconciled to their creator, given
Christ righteousness in full, sealed
with the Holy Spirit, made a new
creature in Christ, and have peace with
God. They are born again of the spirit,
adopted into his family, and are granted
eternal resurrection life in Jesus
Christ, set free to do good works that
please him. Jesus will physically return
one day to judge the living and the
dead, throwing the wicked out of his
kingdom. But his people will be spared
from that wrath that's to come to dwell
in union with God forever.
So the gospel which again means good
news is good news about God's own enter
entering into his own creation
accomplishing the redemption of the
creation establishing his kingdom
reconciling sinners to himself such that
they are completely forgiven adopted
into his family from a fallen condemned
family of Adam made children of God by
being in Christ they have peace with God
and they are made new creatures in
Christ which is 2 Corinthians 5:17 to
one day be resurrected and given
glorification the curse at that point
will be lifted off of the creation and
God's people will inherit the earth to
dwell with their maker forever. So the
call is to turn from your sin to Christ
by faith and find peace with your maker
enjoying him forever. So the foundation
for all of this is ultimately stated in
1 Corinthians 15 1-4 the standard gospel
passage and presentation that people
often point to which is the person and
work of Jesus. All of this stuff is
downstream of the person and work of
Jesus. So that is the message in a
nutshell. It is also trinitarian by the
way. So if you have the wrong god, you
have the wrong gospel. Um but now let's
look at some Adventist theologians.
Okay. Now let's see how the Adventist
gospel um which they have branded as I
mentioned last week and many other times
before as the everlasting gospel
compares with this. So last week I
mentioned the doctrines that the
Adventist church has attributed to being
the gospel but are not. However, for
those that are not familiar with all
this, including some Adventists even,
there is a reason why those doctrines
have been added and why they are
necessary. So, we're going to unpack
that a little further. I think there,
excuse me, may have been a little bit of
confusion last time, so hopefully this
will clarify. First, I want to look at a
paper here from Dr. Herbert Douglas.
We've looked at portions of this on the
channel before
um but we have not looked at um as much
as we are going to tonight. For those
that don't know, Herb Douglas was the
president of the Adventist Weimar
Institute, uh was the associate editor
at the Adventist Review, an Adventist
pastor, was a university professor, I
believe, uh religion professor. Um all
that to say, uh if he isn't qualified to
speak on this, then no Adventist that
joins tonight will be either. So, like I
said, let's look at this paper. It is
titled, "What is the everlasting
gospel?" Okay.
And I want you to notice here
what he starts off by saying.
So, he says, "John the revelator saw
that sometime before the end of the
world," let me zoom in on this for you
guys. I'm sorry.
There you go.
So he says, "John the revelator saw that
sometime before the end of the world,
before Jesus returned, a movement would
arise having the everlasting gospel to
preach to those who dwell on the earth
to every nation, tribe, tongue, and
people, saying with a loud voice, fear
God and give glory to him, for the hour
of his judgment has come." Revelation
146-7.
So right out of the gate, a number of
Adventist assumptions are present. So
Mr. Douglas just assumes that the
Adventist understanding of esquetology
is true. That's problem number one, that
Revelation 14 is automatically talking
about the 19th century onward. That's
what he's defining as the end of the
world, which he's not the only one doing
this. We'll see some other stuff here,
but premillennial esquetology is a part
of this everlasting gospel message by
necessity. Because if you reject
premillennialism,
even historicism, then this whole thing
can't work. So it's by necessity also a
part of this. No room for any other
option and it's elevated to the level of
being part of the gospel. But also
notice he says that John saw that a
movement would rise up having the
everlasting gospel. No. Revelation 14
does not say this. This is the Adventist
interpretation of the text. But nowhere
does the text say anything at all
regarding the three angels representing
a 19th century American movement. let
alone one let alone one that is born
that was born out of a failed prophecy
with christoologgical heretics leading
the charge. Ellen White claimed this
over and over and over again um that the
angels are representative of the seventh
adventist church but the scriptures do
not say this. This is the Adventist
interpretation and porting that into the
text. Uh for those that don't know the
Adventist church ultimately by way of
Ellen G. White, like I said, um, over
and over and over, they are the angels
that are represented by the three angels
there in Revelation 14. And they've been
entrusted with this end times present
truth message to take to the rest of the
world. So, this is why the teaching that
they are the remnant is part of this
gospel as well. That's where this gets
worked in. But he says the everlasting
gospel that goes to all tribes, nations,
peoples, and tongues is the message the
Adventist church is heralding. So, no
one else. So, Revelation 14 to them
isn't talking about the gospel that's
been going to all tribes, tongues,
peoples, nations from the time of the
apostles. That fell away in its fullness
and it needed to be restored as we will
see him say uh shortly. So, what
Christians believe will be labeled as a
limited gospel. That's what he calls
that. So, remember from last week,
Galatians 1, we looked at this I don't
know how many times just on that stream.
Paul very clearly says there is only one
gospel. Not two, not three, not four,
one. any other gospel is no gospel at
all. And he says those who proitize a
false gospel are cursed by God. And he
tells us the only true gospel came from
Jesus Christ himself. And Jesus did not
reveal a different cursed gospel to John
in the revelation, having already
revealed the gospel to John prior to the
revelation. So nevertheless, these sorts
of presuppositions, they are laden
throughout this whole system, which it's
really a symbiotic relationship. You
have to assume the Adventist system is
true and its core pillars to then go
down the doctrinal river, so to speak,
to end up at the destination that
they're trying to lead you to. But let's
look at the footnotes. He lays out some
of the great controversy theme. And
that's the driving factor for this whole
thing. Notice what he says here. We'll
just start. So, he's talking about the
the Greek here for the word hour. And
notice what he says about this. So hour
refers to the time when something will
take place here referencing the time of
his judgment. In the context of the
great controversy theme of cosmic
conflict between Christ and Satan aka
the great controversy pervading the book
of revelation. The basic issue. So
notice that the great controversy is how
revelation is to be understood. It's
through the lens of the great
controversy. The basic issue is over the
fairness of God and his laws. The Bible
nowhere says this. This is again great
controversy fiction being read into the
Bible. This idea that Satan began
rebelling because he was jealous that
Jesus was exalted and be guarded. Well,
I'll save it because we're going to get
into some of that in a bit. But he says
Satan has resisted God and made war
against him. All it says in in
Revelation is that Satan began making
war against God. It doesn't say anything
about because he was Jesus was exalted
to be made equal with the father and
Satan was fighting against the law and
saying it's not fair and consulted an
angel during all this to see if he could
get a a special meeting with Jesus to
discuss like all this extra stuff that
gets ported into it. Throughout human
history, Satan has been charging that
God is severe, exacting unfair and
arbitrary. And God has been telling his
side of the conflict through his
messengers, which is prophets, and
finally, most forcefully revealed this
character through an incarnated member
of the Godhead, Jesus Christ. Men and
women must see that God is not the kind
of person Satan has made him out to be.
They must choose to ally themselves with
him against evil. The contrast is
between or the contrast between Satan
charges Satan's charges and God's loving
is ju uh and just sorry folks I don't
have the same view that all of you do.
There we go. Let's start back here. They
must choose to ally themselves with him
against evil. The contrast between
Satan's charge and God's loving and just
ways must be clearly seen so thinking
beings may make an intelligent choice,
especially in the end times when
Christ's second advent will end
probation, the period of testing for
that last generation. So this whole
thing is downstream of this whole great
controversy theme. That's what's really
going on here. without the great
controversy theme to filter all this
through, you can't get to this
everlasting gospel that they're
proclaiming because nowhere in the Bible
does it say all of the stuff about Satan
attacking God's law and being jealous of
Jesus's exaltation and the authority he
was given, etc. Again, this is a
symbiotic cycle where you have to assume
the great controversy worldview to make
all this work. And the great controversy
worldview isn't coming from scripture,
but it's supposedly coming from God just
through Ellen White. But anyways, he
continues,
little bit of a long one here. So he
says, "The everlasting gospel focuses on
one, God to whom worship and obedience
are due, and on two, a people who give
glory to him during the time of his
judgment." Why is this emphasis on the
everlasting gospel so timely, so
important, so necessary? Apparently,
there was something about the gospel
that had been muted or muddled for some
time before the events seen in
Revelation 14, requiring this special
heavenly intervention to set matters
right, especially at this foretold time
of his judgment. A brief overview of
church history for the past 2,000 years
highlights the remarkable confusion
regarding the gospel that has existed
since apostolic days. Where would one go
during the Protestant Reformation to
find the fullness of the everlasting
gospel? With whom should we agree,
Luther or Calvin or Zwingley? The
Anabaptists or the papacy when it comes
to what is involved in the plan of
salvation in the 19th century? Would we
agree with Presbyterians or Methodists
or Baptist?
Most Protestants
and Catholics would agree that Jesus
died for our sins. But this common
agreement in itself did not and does not
seem to spell out a common understanding
of the gospel. If the gospel includes
more than telling the story of Christ's
death, what is that something more? And
why was an end times correction needed
in order for God to get his final
message across to seekers of truth
before Jesus returns? So notice he's
just bringing the great controversy
theme to the table, which is what's
producing these questions. If you don't
bring that to the table, you're not
going to be asking these questions
because you're not going to be making
the assumptions you're making. The
question seems to stare us in the face.
What is so helpful, so unambiguous about
this everlasting gospel that it tells
the truth about God and prepares a
people for his coming? So notice this
phrase at the end there, prepares a
people. We will come back to this later,
but it's inside baseball for a number of
things that are a part of this
everlasting gospel. Just remember that,
but he says this everlasting gospel
deals with worship and obedience to God
and a people who give glory to him in
his time of judgment. So this is how
young earth creationism gets roped into
this. If you don't believe young earth
creationism, you are supposedly not
worshiping the right God. So since it
says worship him who made heaven and
earth, if you're not, you don't believe
young earth creationism, you have the
wrong god. So you're not doing that.
Same with going to church on Saturday
there. That's the seal of God's true
people supposedly the sign of loyalty to
the creator. So that's how the seventh
day Sabbath gets roped into this as well
as the chapter 13 about the mark of the
beast. If you don't have those two
things, you don't truly love God because
you're disobedient and you don't have
the right God. So, this is also where
the investigative judgment gets
pigeonholed. The phrase the hour of his
judgment, it didn't originally when they
were Millerites. Um, it was obviously at
that time they thought the judgment was
going to be upon the wicked that's
discussed in Revelation 14, but then
they had to figure out some way to
pivot. And so, the development of the
investigative judgment became what is
now ported in there. So, the hour of his
judgment is a judgment only for God's
people. That's what's in view there in
Revelation 14. Folks, read Revelation
chapter 14 and uh see who is in focus
there and if it's God's people. But
yeah, the phrase the hour of his
judgment refers supposedly to the
investigative judgment starting in 1844.
So the investigative judgment and
sanctuary doctrines are ported into this
as well. So that's how they're a part of
this. But then he said, so notice this.
He said, "Apparently, there was
something about the gospel that had been
muted or muddled for some time before
the events seen in Revelation 14,
requiring the special special heavenly
intervention to set matters right,
especially at this foretold time of his
judgment. So, in this system, the
fullness of the gospel fell away almost
immediately after the apostles. And it
required a heavenly intervention to set
things straight, which required God
raising up the Seventh Advenist Church,
his last day remnant people. This is
why, as we will see shortly, countless
theologians and scholars in their
movement have said that the message of
the SDA church uh that they're herald
heralding was never around before or
preached by anybody else. Not the
apostles, not the church fathers, not
the reformers, no one. It is a present
truth message. Another necessary
assumption, by the way, for the system
to work, present truth, that it's only
for this end times period from 1844 to
the second coming. It couldn't be
preached in those other generations.
They may have preached the cross of
Christ, but that isn't the focus of this
everlasting gospel. This everlasting
gospel is a bunch of stuff on top of the
person and work of Christ, which they
are also wrong on, as we will see. But
this showcases another one of the
foundationally faulty assumptions,
and that's this idea that the gospel
wasn't around in its fullness, which
would mean a false gospel according to
Paul. You take anything away or you add
anything, it's a false gospel.
So during the reformation or even prior
to that the gospel was gone. It is
assumed this gospel is some unique good
news distinct to the end of the world
which is why you wouldn't have found it
anywhere else or any time before. And
then this is follow then he follows it
up right there. The one that's
highlighted on screen. He follows it up
with another faulty assumption and
that's the idea that Lutheran,
Presbyterians, Baptists, etc. all have
different gospels. This is not true
because the gospel is not all of your
theology. We got into some of that last
week as well. It's a specific message of
good news. It's not systematic theology
like. Anyways, you know what this sounds
strikingly similar to for those that are
not familiar with this?
The plan of salvation in Mormonism.
So, let me share this here.
Mormonism has an identical thing here.
And Mormonism was around before the
Seventh Adventist Church. This is on
their website, church ofjesus.org.
You can read this for yourself. We're
not going to read the whole thing here,
but I just want to read to you a couple
parts of this because we're going to end
up looking at more of it later, but
notice what it says.
In the primordial existence, so we have
this pre-earth origin story just like
Adventism. Heavenly Father prepared a
plan to enable us to become like him and
receive the fullness of joy. In their
theology, that's to become a God like
him. The scriptures refer to this plan
as the plan of salvation. And they quote
their own scriptures there. The great
plan of happiness, the plan of
redemption, and the plan of mercy. The
plan of salvation is the fullness of the
gospel.
It includes the creation, the fall, the
atonement of Jesus, and all the laws,
ordinances, and doctrines of the gospel.
Moral agency, the ability to choose and
act for ourselves is also essential
essential in Heavenly Father's plan.
Because of this plan, we can be
perfected through the atonement, receive
a fullness of joy, and live forever in
the presence of God. Our family
relationships can last through entire or
through the uh eternities.
same thing going on there, which again,
we're going to do some comparison on
this, but all these groups claim the
same thing. The fullness of the gospel
fell away. We're here to restore it. Um,
you guys are are all wrong. All your
creeds and confessions are an
abomination. Those are the words of
Joseph Smith. But the same thing was
said by the SDA pioneers. All the the
heretical trinitarian creed and just
they're all saying the same stuff. So,
all that to say, what Dr. Douglas is
saying here is not true. Um, let me
bring that back up for us.
It's not true. This is why I so heavily
emphasized last week that the gospel is
not every single doctrinal belief that
somebody holds to. It's a specific
message of good news. What
differentiates these denominations is
secondary doctrinal matters,
not different gospels.
I can go to a Baptist church and worship
just as as in harmony and unity as I can
at my Presbyterian church. I can go to a
non-denominational church.
Obviously, looking at the the
statements, it doesn't necessarily mean
that they're going to be sound just
because they have that label on there.
But the the general point that I'm
saying is it's not different gospels.
But lastly, he mentioned the gospel
entailing more than Christ's death. And
while yes, it isn't simply saying Jesus
died and that's the end of it. Um his
death, burial, and resurrection are
absolutely the hinge upon which the
gospel rests. It's the work of Jesus
Christ on behalf of sinners and creation
that the good news is actual good news.
It is through the work of Christ's
kingdom being established, the creation
redeemed, death, sin, Satan defeated.
This is absolutely foundational to the
gospel. And when Paul told the church at
churches, I guess I should say it,
Corinth, that he decided to know nothing
amongst them except Christ and him
crucified. 1 Corinthians 2:2. He wasn't
saying the only knowledge he had in his
entire mind was this, but that he was
choosing to reveal that to them. That's
that's all he wanted to focus on in
revealing to them. That was the focus of
Paul's message. That was the central
foundation. Everything else was
downstream of that. So in 1 Corinthians
15 1-4, again, the classic gospel
presentation chapter, Paul does does
that exact same thing. He presents the
heart of the gospel, the death, burial,
and resurrection of Christ, verses 1-4,
and then transitions into the benefits
of that work, being made a new creature
in Christ, reconciling to God, our
resurrection, etc., which he expounds
upon um elsewhere as well. But that is
not what Herb Douglas is getting at. He
says this everlasting gospel is an end
times correction to what has been being
preached for 2,000 years. And it's a
message to prepare people for the second
coming. In Adventism, it's about get
prepared. Get prepared. Get prepared. A
prepared people. A prepared people,
which again, we're going to get into
that. He actually said it was necessary
for this to be the case so God could use
uh or could get his message across to
seekers of truth. So, this end times
correction was absolutely necessary to
get the truth. So, this explains why
they see the Adventist message as life
or death because it's what one needs to
believe and adhere to in order to be
prepared for the second coming.
accepting Christ as savior and lord,
turning to him in faith and repentance,
receiving the Holy Spirit as a seal of
one's one salvation, which is a down
payment from God himself of the
inheritance that one has in Christ. That
is not enough to be prepared for the
second coming. You have to get on board
with the distinctly Adventist message.
And then he continues, now catch this
folks.
One of the several ways of defining the
everlasting gospel would be to ask three
questions.
Why did Jesus die? What did he come to
or why did he come to earth? And what is
the purpose or goal of the gospel?
So the everlasting gospel according to
him entails defining one why Jesus died,
why he came to earth and what the
purpose of the gospel is. Within this
statement, you also see the underlying
dichotomy between what he calls the
everlasting gospel and just the gospel.
So in this statement, the gospel is a
certain thing in message, but the
everlasting gospel is a different one
that includes more information on top of
that.
One of the several ways of defining the
everlasting gospel would be to ask those
three questions.
Again, there's only one gospel. It isn't
different when you add the word
everlasting in front of it. It's simply
a way of denoting the gospel's
transcendence. It's not describing some
other thing for the end of the world.
But he states that why Jesus died and
why he came to earth are a part of the
how um that they part of how they define
this everlasting gospel. So remember
this as we will come back to this as
well with some sources um a bit a bit
down the road. But then down a little
further he explains
under a heading called the purpose of
the gospel.
Again, the ellipse of truth helps us
wrap together the two amazing purposes
embedded in Christ's mission to earth
and why he died and the purpose of the
gospel. The purpose of the gospel is to
make plain why Jesus came and why he
died. The everlasting gospel, there's
again that that dichotomy. The purpose
of the gospel is to make plain why Jesus
came and why he died. But the
everlasting gospel in the end times
restores the New Testament gospel in its
wholeness, in its integrity. It explains
God's plan to save men and women in such
a way that their presence in the new
earth would not jeopardize again the
well-being and security of the universe.
Thus, the gospel is not limited to the
good news of his pardon and forgiveness.
It presents the ellipse of truth that
reveals the integrity of God's grace as
including his forgiveness and his power
to transform.
This gospel gospel ellipse is revealed
beautifully in the book of Hebrews as
mercy and grace to help. Let us
therefore come boldly to the throne of
grace that we may obtain mercy and find
grace to help in time of need. John
expressed the same good news as
forgiveness and cleansing. If we confess
our sins, he is faithful and just to
forgive us our sins
and cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
1 John 1:9, Paul saying,"For I'm not
ashamed of the gospel of Christ, for
it's the power of salvation for everyone
who believes has faith." And that's
Romans 1:16. Again, the dichotomy. The
everlasting gospel adds much more to
limited gospels that focus only on one
half of the gospel ellipse.
The religion of Christ means more than
the forgiveness of sins. It means taking
away our sins and filling the vacuum
with the graces of the Holy Spirit. It
means a heart emptied of self. The glory
of the fullness, the completeness of the
gospel plan is fulfilled in the life. So
listening again to Revelation 14,
the everlasting gospel will get a fair
and full hearing in the end times.
Limited gospels that ridicule adherence
to God's expressed will as being outside
of the gospel will appear inadequate
beside the clear proclamation of the
everlasting gospel. Limited gospels that
cry legalism at any attempt to embrace
faithful obedience will be seen as
contrary to the message of the New
Testament grace or a message of New
Testament grace and then a bunch of his
proof text. So a lot here
important to note he falsely contrasts
their everlasting gospel with a false
gospel. He doesn't just contrast it and
say the everlasting gospel and the
gospel. What he then presents as the
gospel is a straw man. It's a false
cursed gospel. He says the gospel only
focuses on pardon and forgiveness but
not on a changed life. And by that he
means what Christians believe. This is
totally false as we saw in what I showed
earlier. This is a classic false
dichotomy the SDA church regularly
makes. But he says the everlasting
gospel actually entails the idea of
obedience and a changed life. Again, as
if what Christians affirm as the gospel
doesn't encompass a changed life. I I
mean
doesn't encompass a changed life. I'm
harping on being a new creature in
Christ constantly. Union with Christ
constantly. I said that phrase probably
20 times last stream. Like what are you
talking about, man?
Doesn't include a changed life. It It's
just It's a straw man. It This whole
thing is built on beating up straw men.
It's just crazy. It's almost hard to
take it seriously when this is supposed
to be the top echelons of SDA
scholarship. It's such a bad
misrepresentation. Are there people out
there like that? Of course. What if I
used just a a Joe Schmo SDA and then
said, "Well, that's that's all SDAs." I
try and specify what I'm saying. And I I
try and always clarify. I know you're
not, you know, last week I did that.
Hey, I know that you're not um you know,
you don't speak for every SDA or
whatever it may be, but of course you
can find some crackpot that you know, of
course that doesn't show me the
confession, Dr. Douglas, which I know
that he has passed, but it's like, show
me the confession that is is accepted by
any sort of mainstream Christian group
that doesn't actually talk about any
sort of changed life. It's just it's
it's hard to take serious again,
especially for people like myself who
had a very radical conversion to Christ.
But nevertheless, notice that first
paragraph. We scroll back up here.
He says, "The purpose of the gospel is
to make plain why Jesus came and died.
The everlasting gospel, on the other
hand, which it includes that message,
but that's not all of it. It supposedly
restores the fullness of the New
Testament gospel to its wholeness and
explains God's plan to save people in
such a way that their presence in the
new earth would not be jeopardized.
Again, this is where the doctrine of the
sanctuary and the investigative judgment
come into play. That's what he means by
God's plan to save. That's what that
phrase means. Christ's work in the
sanctuary. The sanctuary is the the plan
to save. So, they teach this sanctuary
model is God's plan of salvation for
humanity. and it was revealed during
this time. So, we got a glimpse into
this last week regarding one of our SDA
guests who walked through some of these
steps of the sanctuary. And that's
exactly why and this plan is necessary,
they say, to keep sin from entering into
the new earth like it did in heaven with
Lucifer.
So, this is where the concept of
probation now comes into play that God
places everyone on who professes faith
in Christ on probation. They'll say,
"Well, everybody's on probation."
But you continue on probation. It's it's
extended for you to see if they can be
trusted in the new heaven and the new
earth. So, you're on a test right now.
That's why God created Adam and Eve
supposedly. That's what Ellen White said
is to be put on a test. And they failed.
And then God gave them a second chance.
So, they're on we're on a test right now
to see if you can with the help of the
Holy Spirit keep the ten commandments
perfectly and demonstrate that they can
be trusted in the new earth and not let
sin enter in again. That is not what
Hebrews 12 says, folks. Go read it. Go
camp out in Hebrews 12. the end there
when it compares and contrasts Mount
Zion, heaven, with Mount Zion or Mount
Si, the author tells us why sin will not
enter again. And it's because of Christ
in his perfect work purifying all things
and reconciling the world to himself. It
has nothing to do with someone getting
to a sinlessly perfect state now to show
God that they can be trusted. This is a
very man- centered, anthropocentric
view. Hebrews 12 is, well, all of the
Bible, but Hebrews 12 is God- centered.
sin will not enter in again because of
Jesus. So, it's just an interesting
insight into their faulty understanding
of glorification as well, I might add,
which I'm going to do a video on at some
point because it's kind of in
conjunction with the video that went up
on Monday and which um I've had a number
of people reach out who were kind of
confused um SDAs. But nevertheless,
again, this is where the sanctuary and
investigative judgment come into all of
this along with their teaching on
probation. All of which comes as a part
of this everlasting gospel. So, that's a
part of this as well. probation,
present truth, investigative judgment,
young earth creationism, Sabbath.
I'm sure many of you who are new to this
have a spinning head right now. And
hopefully it's showing you why SDAs have
such a hard time grasping the simple
gospel. All this craziness and confusion
and that's labeled the gospel and now
they're unable to like navigate and
understand like what's what. But
something very telling. Notice how he
cited Romans 1:16.
He cited Paul
when referring to the gospel and then
immediately contrast that with the
everlasting gospel by saying the
everlasting gospel adds much more to
limited gospels. So Paul was preaching a
limited gospel according to this
which we will see some sources later
that show this to be the case. The
apostles were not preaching this
everlasting gospel, just the gospel,
which is a limited message because they
weren't in this 1844 to end times
period.
Are you seeing the issue, folks? This is
not the same message preached by the
apostles.
They'll say, "No, no, no. We we affirm
the cross of Christ." Yeah. And you're
just adding a bunch of stuff on top of
it. That's not the gospel. You're making
your whole system of theology, the
gospel, saying you have to join this
system in order to be in the fullness of
the truth and to be able to make it in
the end and through the time of trouble.
And just we'll get into some of that.
The Apostle Paul wasn't even preaching
what they call the everlasting gospel.
That is a problem which again they
wrongfully assume isn't the same single
gospel revealed by Jesus Christ. There
is no such thing as limited gospels and
the everlasting gospel. There is the
gospel, the one gospel, and a bunch of
false cursed gospels.
And there's all sorts of them out there.
We just looked at one earlier, the
Mormons. False cursed gospel, false god.
If you're a Mormon and you hear this,
you need to repent. You have a false
gospel and a false god. He says, "These
limited gospels bring up the charge
that what the Adventists are preaching
is legalism."
So, this is a common tactic. If you're
going to engage with them
apologetically, be prepared for this.
They have done this for for decades. You
can read their well not just that I mean
from the beginning you can read their
pioneers and the charge of legalism is
brought against this message because it
is definitionally by the book legalism.
It isn't just crying legalism because
they claim to preach obedience but
that's how they'll try and position it.
If you disagree with this oh you just
hate obedience. You just don't want to
be obedient to God. Oh how convenient,
right? Thanks for the nice little
backhanded compliment there. So, if you
have an issue with their system, it's
just that you don't like obedience,
which this is patently absurd and
totally false. Their system is
legalistic because it melds both law and
gospel together, making salvation a face
a faith plus the 10 obedience to the ten
commandments being how you're reconciled
to God. Which is why I focused in on
that in particular last week, and I will
again later. The charge of legalism is
brought because it's actual legalism,
not simply because they claim to uphold
obedience. Now, notice the final
sentence of the paper.
Only God's grace can qualify
the redeemed to be safe to save.
So much packed into this statement that
if you aren't familiar with the system,
you won't grasp. But this goes back to
the sanctuary and investigative judgment
which they again read into the phrase in
Revelation 14, the hour of his judgment
has come. That's supposedly about the
investigative judgment starting in 1844.
God has set up this method of saving his
people because in the great controversy,
as we saw in the footnotes to some
degree, Satan is supposedly attacking
God's law by saying it can't be kept
perfectly. This now gets into the claims
he talked about earlier. One, why did
Jesus come and why what did he have to
do? We will look at a couple of quotes
regarding this in a moment. But in the
sanctuary system of salvation, God has
to show who he is or or or who is and
and isn't safe to save. So by safe, he
means those who God can rightly save
because all sorts of heavenly
intelligences and other worlds just like
Mormonism, all these other worlds and
other heavenly intelligences that they
believe in, they're all looking in on
what's going on on Earth. And God has to
clear his name of Satan's accusations to
satisfy these other beings and show that
he's actually who he says he is.
I'm going to say that again.
God has to clear his name of Satan's
accusations
to satisfy these other beings and show
that he's actually who he says he is.
So in this model, God's hands are tied.
He is beholden to Satan's accusations in
this controversy. And so the sanctuary
model is supposedly God's way of showing
all creation that he's just and fair in
saving who he saves as well as that his
law can be kept perfectly is totally
fair, etc. This will then silence the
accusations of Satan in this controversy
and show that God is who he says he is.
They'll say it's ultimately about God
vindicating his character, which is just
another example to see how this whole
system is built and the implications of
what it produces. So hopefully you are
seeing as well um how intertwined all of
this stuff is and why the Adventist
system as a whole is considered the
gospel. This is why
Adventists often claim, like I said
earlier, they have a hard time grasping
that different denominations do not have
different gospels. They associate the
gospel with one's entire system of
theology like they have. And then since
different denominations have some things
they disagree on, that must mean they
all have different gospels. No, this is
incorrect. Now, as it pertains to the
Jesus of Adventism
and why he came, why he had to die,
remember he said that the everlasting
gospel also entails what one believes
about that. So, you also have to affirm
the SDA view of why Jesus came and why
he died.
So, I want to look now at a few quotes,
Ellen White, regarding precisely why
they believe Jesus came and why he had
to die. So, we looked at some of these
last week. Again, I'm for those that
might be joining going a little bit long
tonight. So, we'll see if we're able to
get to some questions later. We are
going to be interacting with some
individuals, but it's going to be via
screenshot because they decided to block
me online and not come on to the show to
discuss. So, we'll just have to interact
with the uh the screenshots. But, we
looked at some of these last week and
I'm trying to kind of put some skin on
the bones, if you will, to kind of
connect the dots because I know a little
um or a few people at least reached out
and had um some questions. So, we looked
at some of these last week. Hopefully,
this will explain why and help connect
the dots for people who aren't as
plugged in to all of this. So, notice
what she says here.
Again, we're answering the question of
why did Jesus, why did Jesus come and
why did he die? This is why in
Adventism, this is only one of many.
We looked at this quote last week.
Through Christ, a door of hope was
opened. that man, notwithstanding his
great sin, should not be under the
absolute control of Satan. Faith in the
merits of the Son of God would so
elevate man that he could resist the
devices of Satan. Probation would be
granted him in which through a life of
repentance and faith in the atonement of
the Son of God, he might be redeemed
from his transgression of the Father's
law, and thus be elevated to a position
where his efforts to keep his law could
be accepted. Close quote. Spirit of
prophecy, volume one, page 49.
Notice, too, when she says the word
atonement, they don't believe in a
completed atonement. It's another reason
this is a false gospel. Second phase of
atonement. That's a bloodless work up in
heaven. Nonsense.
So, she says, "Christ came to open the
door of salvation, making it a
possibility. Faith in his merits, then
elevates you to a point of being able to
resist Satan. Probation is granted to
you so that through a life of repentance
and faith, you can be redeemed from
breaking the law and be elevated to a
position where your efforts to keep the
law can be accepted.
Faith, good. Repentance, good.
Probation, uh, no. Being elevated by
faith to a point where your lawkeeping
can be accepted, nope. Truth mixed with
grave error.
So, they're teaching a probation, like I
said, is a part of this gospel message.
You have to have that as well. It's not
just this general idea of,
"Oh, everybody's on that." That's the
one I hear constantly. Oh, everybody's
on probation. No, everyone is not.
Again, it's just taking a a general
concept and then pouring so much extra
stuff into it outside of just the bare
the bare word to try and act like, "Oh,
well, everyone's on probation." No, you
guys have a have a distinct thing going
on here. But remember, Paul tells us the
gospel is the power of God for salvation
to all that believe it. So if this is
part of the gospel, you have to believe
probation apparently as well. Another
quote,
longer one here
today. The question is to come home to
every heart. Do not believe uh do do you
believe in the son of God? The question
is not do you admit that Jesus is the
redeemer of the world and that you
should rep uh repeat to your soul and to
others believe. All you have to do is
believe. But do you have practical faith
in the Son of God, so that you bring him
into your life and character until you
are one with him? Many accept of the
theory of Christ, but they make it
manifest by their works that they do not
know him as the Savior who died for the
sins of men, who bore the penalty of
their transgression, in order that they
might be brought back to their loyalty
to God, and through the merits of a
crucified and risen Savior, might find
acceptance with God in their obedience
to his law. Christ died to make it
possible for you to cease to sin. And
sin is transgression of the law. Close
quote. Again, lot of truth. Big- time
error. So, why did Christ die? That
people might find acceptance with God by
their obedience to the law. Christ died
to make it possible for you to cease to
sin. So, it isn't your faith alone in
Christ that finds you acceptance with
God.
Faith in Christ is merely the instrument
that allows your lawkeeping to be able
to be seen as acceptable in this system.
It elevates you to an exalted state
where your lawkeeping can be seen as
acceptable. But notice the false
dichotomy she presented. The immediate
response you will get from SDAs will be
she's simply talking about a living
faith that James says. You can't just
mentally check boxes and say you believe
if there you know isn't any fruit. To
which I say that's not the issue with
the quote.
the issues with the red emboldened text.
Again, truth mixed with error, which is
a frequent occurrence with her. She'll
say something great, plagiarize from
somebody sound, followed by another
thing that's great, and then finish it
with a poison pill.
This statement, by the way, folks, isn't
in reference to post glorification,
meaning the condition believers will be
in after they are resurrected,
which is when one will truly become
completely free of sin. She's talking
about in your present condition.
Christ died to make it possible for you
to cease sinning entirely right now
prior to glorification. Adventist, you
are deceiving yourself if you think you
have done that. You are deceiving
yourself if you think you're going to
get there before being glorified. You
are a sinner. Accept it. Turn to Christ.
Trust in Christ.
which is this is which it wasn't this
exact quote but this is why we got into
sinless perfectionism last week with the
first guest and whether or not Ellen
advocated for total sinlessness or just
one try one trying their best
and I insisted she taught total sinless
perfection by the book sinless
perfectionism not just this flavor of
Christian perfection they often try to
reference trying your best but we will
see in a later quote this is not the
case because she states that
glorification will not actually change
anything about your your sinful
character. Hence why you have to get to
a point now. That's why you're on
probation.
Glorification will only change your
ability to live forever, not anything
about your character. So, you have to
get to a point of character perfection
right now and prove that you are safe to
save.
Look at this quote from Sons and
Daughters. This is the this was actually
the book that the first guest last week
took umbrage with. If you recall, same
book. This book is, for those that don't
know, this book is it's kind of like a
devotional. Um, it goes like month by
month and has a message for young people
each day of the year. This one is
January 3rd. Notice what she says. This
is about glorific or Christ returning
and what that's going to be like. We are
not to settle down expecting that a
change of character will come to us by
some miraculous work when Jesus shall
appear in the clouds of heaven with
power and great glory. No, my young
friends, we are judgment bound and
probation is granted us here in this
life in order that we may form
characters for the future immortal life.
Close quote. Sons and daughters, page
nine. So she claims when Jesus returns,
it won't bring with it a change in
character. That's what probation is for
now. So while on probation demonstrating
that you're safe to save and you won't
let sin enter in again in light think
about that in light of what Herb Douglas
was saying earlier
showing how probation is tied into all
of this. If you don't get to a perfect
character now you're not going to make
the cut because no change of character
is going to come with being glorified.
And this is their sanctification model.
You can view this by the way folks over
at uh answering adventism.com. Just type
into the search bar up top
sanctification
and click on the one that says what does
the Adventist church teach about
sanctification and this chart will pop
up. But this is their sanctification
model.
Over time you are gradually imparted
with Christ's righteousness and merits
which make up the difference where you
fall short. But eventually you will need
to get to a state where this doesn't
have to happen anymore because you have
arrived at a sinlessly perfect state
before the close of probation.
Probation will close and you will then
have to stand before almighty God
without an intercessor because Jesus
will move from being intercessor to the
advocate of those who arrive at the
state for the courtroom scene that will
take place in heaven. This is documented
by the way in Christ in his sanctuary
chapter 9. Satan will be there accusing
those who made it through the
investigative judgment and Jesus will be
advocating for them. He will be able to
silence Satan's accusations because
he'll be able to show that they have no
sins on the books and he has the right
to save those individuals.
It's always about again showing God's
fair and just to all the watching
intelligences.
This so all these watching intelligences
can see that God is fair. He can he's
safe to save the people that he's he's
going to save. This whole thing revolves
around God having to vindicate himself.
But all of that is going on while
everyone is still on earth and the time
of trouble comes. So if you haven't
gotten to this sinless state, you won't
be able to stand in the time of trouble.
That's what Ellen said. She said if you
lack the faith to you'll lack the faith
to make it.
She said you'll have to just or you'll
have to be like Christ was in his tempt.
The analogy she uses is Christ's
temptation in the wilderness with Satan.
She said, "Your character will have to
have gotten as perfect as Christ to make
it through the time of trouble."
This is where their total victory and
like I mentioned earlier, a prepared
people teachings come into play in their
system, which are really just buzz
phrases for sinless perfectionism.
So all of that now is a part of this
everlasting gospel.
You have to understand all this stuff
that all this stuff is part of the steps
and the process and the plan of God
vindicating himself. It is this complex
thing. But how insane folks to think
that being given glorification isn't a
miraculous of work that won't impact a
person's entire being, including their
character.
The SDA church does not understand the
doctrine of glorification at all. And
rejecting their faulty understanding
does not then mean that you jump into
the other ditch which says, "So because
this is the case, I don't have to seek
to live a godly life." Like that doesn't
even take into account the fact that
again people being made new creatures in
Christ. All of the stuff last week as
well was honed in and focused in on
union with Christ. That was the whole
context of last week. That's the central
focus of the gospel. Being united to
Christ and receiving all the benefits.
Part of the benefits that come with that
is being made a new creature in Christ.
Being transferred from the kingdom of
darkness into the kingdom of light.
That's going to have necessary ripple
effects. So, like don't jump into the
other ditch if you just reject this
false idea. I've had people comment on
my videos where I've done stuff on
sinless perfectionism and Adventists
will be like, "Well, then what's the
point of even trying?" So, the only
reason for trying is to try and and
prove that you're savable. Like, that's
just silly. Like, no, you you do it
because you love Christ. Like, you're a
chain. You understand what Christ did
for you. That changes you and that
resonates with you. But at the same
time, your flesh has not been swn
perishable to be raised and glorified.
Like it just don't jump into either
extreme. Again, both of those are are
extreme ditches. The war with sin is
going to go on the entire life of the
Christian. You are a sinner until you
are glorified. You will not have a
flawless character identical to that of
Jesus's
or or that of of the new heaven and the
new earth until glorification.
Honestly, it's it's as if this life is a
purgatorial state in Ellen's mind, the
Adventist church's system. So instead of
purgatory being somewhere one goes after
they die to be purified and and then fit
for heaven, it's happening in this life
through your cooperation with God. That
is what will purify your soul. And we
will see um that in a later quote. But
nevertheless, this is also a part of of
what one must believe according to Dr.
Douglas's um everlasting gospel message.
So in a nutshell, their gospel is the
good news that Jesus died to make
salvation possible, opening the door of
possibility, granting man a probationary
period. By faith in Jesus's sacrifice
and merits, you can be given the Holy
Spirit as a helper who will empower you
to be able to keep the law of God. In
doing so, because you are doing so in
faith, Jesus sees your best efforts and
makes up where you fall short. All of
the truly penitent eventually will get
to a state where they are obeying the
law of God perfectly, no longer sinning
at all, demonstrating that God's law can
be kept. This will silence the
accusations of Satan in the great
controversy, showing that God's law is
fair and that Jesus is just and fair in
saving those he saves. This will
ultimately vindicate the character of
God before all the watching
intelligences, and the sins of those
that make it will be placed onto Satan
to then be blotted from existence,
bringing the co the cosmic drama to an
end.
This is not the good news of Jesus
Christ. Yeah. The general thing, getting
rid of sin. He puts sin away at the
cross. Hebrews 9:26. Of course, all this
mumbo jumbo. No. All this stuff coming
from the great controversy theme. Nah,
not the gospel. Last quote from her
regarding the this three angels gospel
they claim to have. Notice what it says
here.
She's talking about seventh adventists
here. In a special sense, seventh
adventists have been set in the world as
watchmen and lightbearers. To them has
been entrusted this last warning for the
perishing world. On them is shining
wonderful light from the word of God.
They've been given a work of the most
solemn import, the proclamation of the
first and second first, second, and
third angel's messages, aka their
everlasting gospel that Dr. Douglas has
been expounding upon.
There is no other work of so great
importance.
They are to allow nothing else to absorb
their attention. The most solemn truths
ever entrusted to mortals have been
given to us to proclaim to the world.
Wow. The proclamation of these truths is
to be our work. The world is to be
warned and God's people, that's the
Adventists, are to be true to the trust
committed to them.
They are not to engage in speculation,
neither are they to enter into business
enterprises with unbelievers, for this
would hinder them in their godgiven
work.
So these supposed truths uniquely given
to them are the most important work in
the entire world to be heralding.
Not what the apostles taught and
preached,
which came directly from the Lord Jesus
Christ. I know they're going to claim,
well, this came from Jesus, too. Yeah,
Jesus gave a cursed gospel to John in
the revelation, right?
Not what the apostles taught, but this
present truth message.
The ones who have this message are
supposedly God's people. That's the
remnant. And it's their duty to take to
the rest of the world specifically
targeted at Christians
because again, your belief in Christ,
your faith in Christ, not good enough.
You have to have more on top of that.
You don't have the fullness of the
light. Christian, the final last warning
from God has been uniquely given to them
to take to the perishing world.
And again, this would mean it was not
around until they were. If it was being
proclaimed by the apostles, then it
would not have been the last warning or
uniquely given to the SDA church.
This is why when some SDAs will tell me
that they reject the investigative
judgment to try and cherrypick and do
like an alakart style adventism, it all
falls apart. You don't understand the
system.
is an all or nothing in this system.
The whole thing as a system requires all
of the teachings to work. If one link in
the chain breaks, the whole system
collapses.
It is not a strong systematic. I've I'm
not saying I'm a systematic theology
expert, but I've studied a number of
systematic theologies and I'm telling
you this one is very weak because it
it's not built upon the foundation, the
rock. The foundation of this movement is
esquetology. It's like, man, you you're
not even right on the on who God is and
what the gospel is. You have zero
business dealing with that's like trying
to ride a a quad.
I don't know what they're called, a
ninja motorcycle before, right? Knowing
how to ride a bicycle. You have zero
business dealing in all that when you
don't even have the foundation, the 101
stuff down. You're trying to go to 401
before you've even got 101 passed.
Now, as it pertains to all the doctrines
that are nestled under this everlasting
gospel umbrella, Dr. Douglas didn't
really mention all of those. You can
read that whole paper, by the way,
folks. Just go on Google and type in
Herbert Douglas, what is the everlasting
gospel, and it's under the uh
andrews.edu archive. Um, he mentioned a
number of buzz phrases and and those
sorts of things, but he didn't mention
all of the specific doctrines. So, let's
look at a couple of quotes here that lay
out
what those specific doctrines are. Okay.
Now, we looked at this last week, and
this was the thing the gentleman, the
first guest said. I don't know who wrote
that. Who wrote that? yada yada. So,
we're going to look at a number of
quotes so you can see this isn't a
one-off.
This isn't something that, oh, it's only
that's just a rogue quote. No, this this
is all over the place. is from 1934
herald and review or review and herald
sorry.
So they say this movement with which we
are connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths.
The existence of God, the inspiration of
the holy scriptures, salvation alone
through the vicarious sacrifice of the
Lord Jesus, repentance, regeneration,
and the gift of righteousness by faith.
Again, all this buzz lingo and having to
define these things. It sounds great.
It's like on that Mormon page, there's
all a bunch of Christianes on there, but
then you start peeling back the layers
how they define that stuff. It's like,
whoa. Same thing's going on here. the
gift of righteousness by faith, the work
of the Holy Spirit, the immutability of
God's law, the binding claims of the
Bible Sabbath, the priestly ministry of
Christ in the heavenly sanctuary, the
investigative judgment now going on, the
soon coming of Christ to take his
children home, the doctrine of spiritual
gifts, the manifestation
of the gift of prophecy in the remnant
church, life only in Christ, Christian
temperance,
and other leading important Bible
doctrines. These great truths constitute
the everlasting gospel message for this
time.
They didn't even include them all. Other
leading important Bible doctrines, aka
the Adventist church's fundamental
beliefs, which is again why I' I've had
a number of people here recently tell
me, "Well, I got baptized in the
Adventist Church. I didn't have to agree
to the fundamental beliefs. They must
have really changed some stuff around."
I'm g have to do some digging on that
because I find that hard to believe. You
you have to affirm the fundamental
beliefs to be baptized in the Adventist
church. That's why because the
fundamental beliefs is the
representation of the everlasting
gospel.
Very plainly it says for this time. It
wasn't the gospel before the SDA church,
but now it is. And notice all the
doctrines listed. That's their gospel.
The Adventist gospel is Adventism.
And they even say in the next paragraph
that this message, well, as we're going
to see, was given to the SDA church,
showcasing yet again, it is a novel,
unique, and different than anything that
came before it message.
When others supposedly preached it, like
Noah, Abraham, etc., it wasn't the same
message because they were in different
settings. But then they'll say, "But
they were preaching the everlasting
gospel, but it was the present truth for
that time."
None of those figures preached that the
gospel was the investigative judgment,
the heavenly sanctuary, the gift of
prophecy, and the remnant church, etc.
Well, right? Because it was for their
time.
The message doesn't just the gospel
doesn't evolve like that. None of them
believe that believing that stuff is the
power of God for salvation.
Like Noah, he's a perfect example they
love to use. Noah preached probation.
There was a limited amount of time
before destruction would come. And
that's supposed to somehow mean that God
created man to be put on a test of uh to
test his loyalty for God and then fell
and Christ came to extend that
probationary period and opportunity and
so on and so on. The story of Noah has
nothing to do with that. That's just
trying to glean way too much. Way too
much. Well, let's go up here. Notice
what he says about some of this or what
they say to the seventh adventist church
has been committed this message. The
everlasting gospel was preached by Noah,
by Abraham, by Paul and Peter, and by
all the prophets and apostles of past
ages. It was preached in the setting
appropriate for their day. We can't
preach this gospel message as Noah
preached it. So then they go into to all
of that stuff.
Well, then it isn't the gospel message.
It's not this present truth evolving
based on
just No.
Again, another article here is from the
1990s now from Robert Fulenberg, the
then president of the SDA church.
Quote, "As 7th Day Adventists, we
believe we have a present truth message
found in the proclamation of the three
angels of Revelation 14. We particularly
note the message of the third angel with
its warning about those who worship the
beast in contrast to those who keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus." is Revelation 14:12. This is
a distinct message for a distinct time,
our time in fact, which is why we deem
it present truth. Close quote. So later
on here, he tries giving the standard
defense that, well, of course, the cross
of Christ is central. That has to be the
foundation.
You don't have to have all this other
stuff to be saved, which is not true at
all, as you will get a glimpse into
shortly. This is just trying to square
away the fact that their message is one
of
that their
it's just trying to to square away the
fact that their message is one of
salvation and it entails all of their
system of theology. It's the whole SDA
package. That's the gospel of Adventism.
And he clearly states this message
wasn't given before the SDA church. It's
for our time, a present truth message.
And like the 1934 article, he follows
the same thing in the next paragraph,
like I said, by trying to say there's an
aspect that's transcended to all times,
but more to that, more to it than just
that. Of course, the cross has to be
central, but there's other doctrines
outside of that. This parallels
perfectly with what Herb Douglas was
saying regarding uh regarding his
compare and contrast between the gospel
and the everlasting gospel. The
everlasting gospel supposedly is the
fullness of the message that everyone
else is lacking. Nope. Galatians 1, it's
clear. You can't add or remove anything
from the singular gospel message. There
are not multiple gospels such as a
limited one and a complete one. There's
the gospel. Anything else cursed by God.
Now, just to hammer it home, I mentioned
this quote last week, but now we'll
actually bring it up and look at it.
This is from J Scheler, 1934. Actually,
that review in Herald was 1936 earlier.
1934. This guy was one of their I don't
know if anyone's broken his record. He
was like the longest evangelist in SDA
history.
Notice what he says.
Or sorry, we need to actually move up to
I think I want to read this one first.
He says, "The prophecy of Revelation
14:6-14 does not and cannot refer to any
proclamation of the gospel in the days
of the apostles, the early Christian
fathers, or the reformers of the 16th,
17th, or 18th centuries. It is strictly
a last day message applicable to those
who live just before the return of
Christ.
Does it get much clearer than that?
I mean, I could go on and on and on on
these quotes. They're all saying this.
So, Adventists out there, if you're
going to call in and say, "Well, no, I'm
these are not oneoffs, folks. This is
the message.
You have to come believe this message to
be prepared for the second coming. He's
coming. He's coming. He's coming. Get
prepared. Come on. Join us. That's the
messaging. That's the truth. They want
to proitize the rest of us to come join
their church because the wrath of God's
going to be poured out. Well, I can't
judge. You know, they'll say, "I can't
judge." And Ellen White had no problem
doing that. Your guys' inspired
prophetists. So,
the Adventist Church is not proclaiming
the same gospel as Christians. It is
something distinct that they think God
revealed to them by way of LG White. The
gospel apparently changed in the last
days which is again the problem in
assuming their definition of the last
days.
Another foundational issue to all of
this. Romans 1:1617 is clear.
The gospel message is the power of God
to salvation for all that believe it.
But lastly here,
let's look at Ephesians 1
3-14.
for those that want to look it up as
well. Ephesians 1 3-14.
And notice what Paul says here about the
gospel.
So after he gives his credentials, which
is pretty standard fair for him.
He goes on to say this.
Blessed be the God and father of our
Lord Jesus Christ who has blessed us in
Christ with every spiritual blessing in
the heavenly places. Already we have
that phrase in Christ. Last week I
harped on this. I'm going to keep
harping on it. It's the foundation union
with Christ. Being in Christ. He's
blessed us with every spiritual blessing
in the heavenly places. That encompasses
all sorts of things.
Even as he chose us in him before the
foundation of the world that we should
be holy and blameless before him in love
he predestined us for adoption. There's
one of the benefits of being in Christ.
In love he predestined us for adoption
to himself as sons through Jesus Christ
according to the purpose of his will to
the praise of his glorious grace with
which he has blessed us in the beloved.
In him, again, that phrase, in him,
union with Christ, we have redemption
through his blood, the forgiveness of
our trespasses according to the riches
of his grace. This is Paul's gospel
bleeding over into the message of being
united to Jesus Christ,
which he lavished upon us in all wisdom
and insight, making known to us the
mystery of his will, according to his
purpose, which he set forth in Christ,
as a plan for the fullness of time to
unite all things in him, things in
heaven, and things on earth.
Now, get this.
This is the kicker. in him. There's that
phrase again. We have obtained an
inheritance.
It's part of the being united to Christ,
part of the benefits of Christ. The
inheritance we have, having been
predestined according to the purpose of
him who works all things according to
the council of his will, so that we who
were the first to hope in Christ might
be to the praise of his glory. Now, here
it is. In him, again, united to Christ.
You also when you heard the word of
truth, the gospel of your salvation and
believed in him
were sealed with the promised Holy
Spirit who is the guarantee of our
inheritance. He just mentioned the
inheritance earlier. He's mentioned a
number of things that come with that
inheritance. Other things like
resurrection,
etc. until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of his glory. There are
aspects of those things that we haven't
acquired possession of yet, but we've
been given the Holy Spirit as a down
payment, a guarantee. He goes on to say
that in chapter 4:30,
2 Corinthians 1:21-22, 2 Corinthians
5:5.
Notice all the inhymns Paul uses,
union with Christ.
He mentions all sorts of benefits that
one receives when they are in Christ. It
is a term of salvation. It deals with
identity. All of the benefits that we
receive by being united to him. In this
paricopy alone, he mentioned adoption in
verse 5, redemption and forgiveness of
sins in verse 7, our inheritance in
verse 11, and then in verse 13, the
kicker. When we believers
heard the word of truth, what is the
word of truth?
the gospel of your salvation.
It's a specific message of good news,
the power of God for salvation. And when
we believed in him, meaning Jesus, it's
his good news. That's the good news.
It's about the person and work of Jesus.
When you believed in him, received the
Holy Spirit as a seal, which is the
guarantee of the inheritance that we
will acquire fully one day. It's the
earnest money to use a business term.
The down payment made by God
guaranteeing us of what we receive. It
is a guarantee.
God does not make down payments that he
doesn't then pay in full. He's not going
to default on his deposit.
Nothing about probation to see if you're
going to be kept in the family after
being adopted or eventually disowned.
No, a person is his. We are his
possession, his workmanship.
a term of new creation. By the way, when
Paul says, "We are his workmanship,"
that's new creatures in Christ. 2
Corinthians 5:17. So when a person hears
the gospel message, believes the gospel,
they are then sealed by God with the
Holy Spirit.
So Adventists, I would love to see where
the gospel Paul preached that he
received from Jesus Christ mentions or
entails a person hearing the
investigative judgment, the seventh day
Sabbath, the health message, present
truth, the spirit of prophecy manifest
in the writings of LG White, and all the
other additions that the SDA church has
added. And that upon hearing all that
and believing it, a person's then sealed
by observing the law and kept by their
due diligence while on a probationary
period to see if they can get to a
perfect character be character to be
trusted in the new earth.
because none of that is in view. And
what Paul says there, it's simple.
Now, for a quick overview of why we
claim that the Adventist church
or the Adventist Jesus rather is not
real and cannot save you. If you have
the wrong Christ, you're going to have
the wrong gospel. Because again, like I
said earlier, the gospel is Jesus Christ
gospel. Galatians 1:12. The Adventist
Jesus is no different than the Mormon
Jesus, the Muslim Jesus, the Jehovah's
Witness Jesus. Total fiction, not real,
false Christ. You can use the name,
that's not enough. There's all sorts of
people out there talking about who Jesus
is. So, here is a sideby-side comparison
of the Jesus we affirm in comparison to
the Adventist Jesus. And these are only
a few of the issues. So, as it pertains
to his nature, the Adventist Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with the
father. He is a separate being from God
the Father and the Spirit.
He was only a man on earth while setting
his divine nature aside. That's the
Kosis heresy video from last week that I
did. He's not almighty.
The father is almighty.
He could have sinned and failed to do
the will of the father perfectly. That's
another one that's not on there.
But he lacks omnipresence
as we looked at in the video as well
from last week. In comparison to the
Jesus of scripture who is eternally
co-equal with the father and the spirit
shares the same being as the father and
spirit.
He retained his entire divinity
incarnate.
He is Yahweh in union with the father
and the spirit and he possesses full
omnipresence.
On top of that,
the Adventist Jesus is still dealing
with sin in a second phase of bloodless
atonement in heaven, doing analogous
work to the Levitical priesthood, even
wearing the Levitical priesthood
garments.
According to Hebrews 6 through10, this
is where Paul goes in and starts
hammering in the the compare and
contrast between the Levitical
priesthood and Jesus's Melkisedcian
priesthood. The Levitical priesthood
work of dealing with sin is finished.
Sin was dealt with and put away at the
cross.
Christ is ruling and reigning as a
priest king after the order of
Melkisedc. Again, MelkiseDC was not just
a priest but a king. The Levites were
not kings.
Jesus entered into the presence of God
one single time and sat down which is
representative which the author mentions
this over and over and over and over
again. It's not just a passing detail.
The original audience would have known
exactly what the author was saying
because they had no concept of the
priest ever sitting. Which is why he
says in the verses that I read earlier,
every priest stands daily, but Jesus sat
down. Means the work was finished. Work
of dealing with sin is done.
Jesus is mediating on behalf of his
people as his enemies are made a
foottool like we also looked at earlier.
But then you compare this to
the Adventist Jesus.
wearing Levitical priesthood garments,
which the book of Exodus, I've done a
video on this for those that are
curious.
The Exodus makes it clear that the
garments had to do with
the line of Aaron. They were unique and
distinct to that and Jesus isn't in that
line. But he was doing a holy place
ministry until 1844
and then didn't enter the most holy
place until 1844.
He's still working on putting sin away.
Again, a bloodless atonement contrary to
Hebrews 9:22
and is investigating to see who are
truly his and who he's just in saving.
This is not the correct person. At a
certain point,
the entire thing just becomes completely
different. An incomplete atonement,
still dealing with sin, Satan bearing
the sins in the end, Levitical
priesthood, Jesus exalted to be made
equal with the father, and on and on and
on. This ain't the Jesus of history and
scripture. If you're an Adventist and
you take umbrage to this, bring it up
and let's discuss and examine. One final
thing before bringing up our first guest
who I mentioned earlier was going to be
coming into us by way of screenshot. to
the Adventists who go around on Facebook
that don't understand um or realize that
I see what you guys are saying
and you don't have the integrity to come
have a discussion, but you make these
public displays in your your echo
chamber
like you're ready to go down on your
sword.
I I'm ready to go down on my sword,
fellas.
Are you
come have a discussion instead of
being um two-faced. One way publicly and
a different way online,
these gentlemen online. We're going to
respond to them really quick and then
we'll respond to another individual,
Edwin Jay, why not come have a dialogue
instead of lying about people when you
think they can't see. So this guy Jay
Huffman, notice what he says here. Hey,
hey, Edwin brother. There's a guy on
YouTube that has a ministry of bashing
Adventism. His name is Miles Kettles and
he has a YouTube channel called
Answering Adventism. He says we have a
false gospel, false god, and that we
make Ellen White equal to or above the
Bible. He's a former third gen SDA.
August 3rd, that's today. He's going to
have an open mic program challenging any
SDA to prove him wrong. That's correct.
Put on your armor, buddy, and help fight
and contend for the faith. To which
Edwin responds, he's an SDA apologist
for those that don't know. He said, 'I'm
aware of him already.' And then this Jay
fellow responds with, "How would you
propose to answer him, General Cado?"
Bro is looking for his marching orders.
And notice what he says. SDA apologist,
folks, look at this.
What do you propose we do?
We refute and destroy him and his
arguments on an equal public platform.
Now, ironically, and I was going to
bring this up last week, but then I was
like, it is what it whatever. But the
previous week, Edwin's buddy Jason Neely
had this to say about yours truly.
A friend tagged me last week in a stream
and well, he tagged last week's stream
and myself in a comment thread asking if
I would be willing to discuss the gospel
with a guy who was going off, I don't
know this guy. And I responded by saying
yes anytime, anywhere. Always prepared
to discuss the gospel.
So this guy Jason then responded to me
after I said that and said Edwin Mcado.
To which I responded, as you can see
here, the comment you see of mine is to
him and I responded with the link to
last week's stream said, "Here you go.
I'd gladly discuss with him if he showed
up, but I know that he won't because
I've had correspondence with him before
and they're all bark and no bite paper
tigers." What did Jason have to say to
this?
Already resulting to insults and name
calling, the spirit in which you share
your convictions reflects that of
bitterness and disdain.
It seems as if you have no desire to
have dialogue,
but rather a debate to try and what?
Destroy your opponent.
No, Jason,
you guys want to see people destroyed.
Your apologists want to see people
destroyed.
Answering Adventism does not exist to
destroy people.
This is a false charge that's often made
to attack my character, my motives, my
heart.
All the SDAs who talk to me privately,
have reached out, etc. They all know
this is baloney. This just rallies up
your echo chamber.
Things like this are said by them folks
because they are mad at what I am doing.
It is what I have branded a triple T
theological temper tantrum.
And unlike people in the past, I won't
back down.
I don't fear their theology.
I was studying for this mission for a
decade before undertaking it. gentlemen,
they don't like that. They don't like
that I know their system and can bridge
the gap for Christians to be able to
better understand the issues.
It blows the cover of the organization,
which they've had for far too long from
the larger Christian community. These
guys don't like that. They're a sheep
stealing organization.
So, they're in damage control mode
trying to attack me personally to
obuscate away from what is actually
being said.
If it were my my desire to destroy
Adventists, I'd say nothing. I'd let
them keep walking toward the cliff to
predition. The very fact that I'm saying
something shows I care about SDAs, which
this is part of the problem. In
Adventism, it's all one big kumbaya
around the campfire. Everyone's patting
each other on the back as if
everything's okay. And it's not.
Millions of people marching toward the
cliff, Bibles in hand, saying nothing is
the equivalent of wanting people
destroyed,
not being bold enough to sound the
alarm.
But recognize the marketked contrast,
folks.
The spirit behind the true gospel over
here and the spirit behind the false
gospel.
One side wants to see people destroyed.
The other wants to see people come to
know a glorious knowledge of the truth
found in the true Christ and his gospel.
That includes these gentlemen
that myself and other Adventists
actually pray for by name.
One side asserts of the other that they
just want people to be destroyed despite
my own words and actions saying
otherwise while the side saying that is
explicitly saying they want people
destroyed. Don't fall for it. Don't fall
for it. If I could trigger that that's
bait meme, I would.
Edwin, you you can destroy me. You can
attack me. You can publicly lie about
me. It's not going to work, my friend.
You You seem confused because this
gospel is not my gospel.
It's Jesus Christ's gospel.
And this gospel is undefeated.
You're not seeking to destroy me. You're
seeking to destroy Christ. And good luck
with that. It is going to be a bad day
for you, sir.
You will simply be in a long line of
individuals down through the centuries
who have fought to destroy this gospel
and have failed.
Communism tried. Rome tried. Mor
Mormonism's tried. Islam's tried.
Secularism's tried. Humanism's tried.
The cult of science has tried. Get in
line.
Jesus Christ doesn't need me, folks. His
kingdom is going to advance by way of
this gospel being proclaimed, regardless
of if I'm around or not.
I'm simply seeking to obey Christ as
best I can and what I feel called le and
led to do. So, while the SDA apologists
have a come apart um about what we're
doing here, we will remain focused on
the mission at hand. Jason, Jay, Edwin,
you all are more than welcome to show up
to an open mic and have a face-to-face
discussion. You saw last week, I didn't
mute anybody. I didn't talk over
anybody. I'm not a mean, nasty person
like you guys claim. You guys don't seem
to understand. There's a context be
behind certain situations. There's a
time and a place for something like
that.
When you have people in in your guys'
midst named destroying false
Christianity who comes in kicking the
door down like that guy from a couple
months ago. Yeah. Then you're going to
be met with that same level of force.
Don't give me that.
But Edwin, like your buddy Jay exhorted
you, step up to the plate, buddy. Come
defend your gospel. You guys supposedly
have the anvil that can wear out any
hammer. So, let's see it. But I don't
think you will. You know why? Because
speaking of destruction and destroying
people, what does the Apostle Paul tell
us in Philippians 1 19-28?
For those that want to check it out,
Philippians 1 19-28.
This is after Paul
talks about some people preaching the
gospel in vain for self-seeking purposes
and others in care and love for people.
That's the contrast he's making. And
then he says that he's in prison for his
defense and proclamation of the gospel
which demonstrates it isn't coming from
a form of self-seeking.
Then after that he says this again
Philippians 1 19-28.
For I know that through your prayers and
the help of the spirit of Jesus Christ
this will turn out for my deliverance.
As it is my eager expectation and hope
that I will not be at all ashamed, but
that with full courage now as always,
Christ will be honored in my body,
whether by life or by death. For to me,
for yeah, for to me to live as Christ
and to die is gain. For if I I am to
live in the flesh, that means fruitful
labor for me. Yet which I shall choose,
I cannot tell. I am hardpressed between
the two. My desire is to dep to depart
and be with Christ, for that is far
better. But to remain in the flesh is
more necessary on your account.
Convinced of this, I know that I will
remain and continue with you all for
your progress and joy in the faith, so
that in me you may have ample cause to
glory in Christ Jesus because of of my
coming to you again. So Paul says he'd
rather die and go be with Christ, but he
knows that for their benefit, it's best
that he remains and that God will
sustain and keep him because of the
mission and the cause at hand. So
besides showcasing that Paul didn't view
the afterlife like the SDA church does,
their view of the state of the dead also
shows a lack of understanding around
union with Christ. By the way, um notice
what he exerts in uh these Philippian
Christians to do starting in verse 27.
Only let your manner of life be worthy
of the gospel of Christ, so that whether
I come and see you or am absent, I may
hear of you, that you are standing firm
in one spirit with one mind, striving
side by side for the faith of the gospel
mentioning earlier different
denominations
united one mind around the gospel, which
means you're united around the same God
as well. That's the foundation. But then
notice what he says. And not frightened
in anything by your opponents.
This the gospel is a clear sign to them
of their destruction, but of your
salvation, and that is from God.
Is lying about people in your Facebook
group claiming you want to see them
destroyed a manner of life worthy of the
gospel?
Christians are united in one mind around
the gospel, which would include the
again the true and living Christ since
it's his gospel. Yes, there may be
secondary doctrinal differences. That's
okay and that's fine. But we stand
united in the gospel of Jesus Christ.
And like Paul says, we're not frightened
by anyone who opposes this gospel and
comes up against it. Why?
It's a clear sign of the destruction of
those who come up against it. But to us,
that's Christians, it's a sign of our
salvation. You oppose the gospel in
favor of your novel present truth
gospel, Edwin. You have a man-made
gospel. So I don't have to do anything
to try and destroy you. The gospel
already has.
Now, with that said, Jay Huffman is
actually going to be our first guest.
And like I mentioned, we're going to
interact with screenshots since he
blocked me after telling him to show up
and engage instead of lying about me.
And so I wanted to respond publicly
because I think this will be beneficial
for those who um are here. So he watched
last week's stream and this is what he
had to say.
Quote, "I have proof that Miles
Kettlesson is lying in taking LG.
White's words out of context and
twisting them in his video titled Prove
Me Wrong: The SDA Church has a false
gospel in Christ." That's last week's
open mic.
which I will not prove uh which I will
uh I will prove him wrong. Here's a
prime example of his deceitfulness.
Under his quote number two, I show the
pictures of the quote of Ellen White
that he put up on the screen and I show
the picture of the actual quote from an
eightpage article in Testimonies for the
Church volume 4, page 20 through 28.
These pictures show you what he left out
and how he twists the words of God's
messenger. The context is moving forward
in faith and obedience to God's word and
commands. It's not talking about how to
be saved.
It's not talking about how to be saved.
He claims
or trying to earn salvation by works.
The title of the article is go forward.
And in the article, Ellen White says the
word go forward seven times, eight if
you count the title. The setting and
context of the story is the Israelites
exodus from Egypt and they're at the Red
Sea and God is commanding them to go
forward to cross the Red Sea. God has
already saved them and delivered them
from bondage. the bondage of Pharaoh by
the blood of the Passover lamb. Now, it
was a question of trust. So, the charge
from the guy who has a second
commandment violation as his profile
picture, by the way, is that I'm a liar.
I'm a deceiver. I took Ellen White out
of context. And this doesn't have to do
with salvation, but trust. Salvation was
already accomplished. She's just talking
about trust and going forward. Jay, you
should have read more carefully, buddy,
um, and done your homework on your
system of theology. The irony of this
statement is that if you actually you
actually missed a vital aspect of the
chapter and why she mentions the
Israelites in the first place, she isn't
primarily talking about them like you
asserted. You also should have listened
more carefully to me, Jay, because
before reading last week's quotes, I
explained the reason for why I was
citing them, and it had to do with a
quick overview of showing Ellen White
had no concept of what?
Union with Christ. Reconciliation.
You know that you can quote something
sometimes folks for a variety of
reasons.
It's not always to for for a specific
purpose. But nevertheless,
this term has to do with the benefits
one receives at the point of being in
Christ. And a systematic reading of the
Apostle Paul on this is clear. When one
is united to Christ, they receive all of
his benefits. One of which is God's
favor. And that comes from being in
Christ.
This is what is signed and sealed in the
Eucharist. by the way, partaking of
Christ, the Eucharist destroys the false
investigative judgment doctrine. But
nevertheless, that was why I cited this.
You don't earn favor by keeping the Ten
Commandments. Neither did Israel. No
one. That isn't how favors earned.
Period. But furthermore, you clearly
went hunting, Jay, for somewhere to try
and find fault because we're going to
read a number of paragraphs now from
those eight pages and show, no, I'm not
a liar, nor am I a deceiver.
You also should have done your due
diligence first, Jay, and visited our
website where we have an entire article
written up on this quote, including the
foundational fountain head quote
regarding Ellen's use of this phrase,
the law earning favor with God, which we
will look at after we read a few
paragraphs here. For those that want to
look at it,
here you go. This is what it looks like
on the website.
You can simply type into the search bar
up here
is obeang
and it'll pop up right there and you can
look at it yourself. And I got all the
hyperlinks in here, Jay. And you know
what? I even address you right here.
Adventist apologists have sought to
defend this by claiming that Ellen
White's statements was not what?
Oh, it wasn't in regards to salvation.
and Jay, I go through and explain with
all the quotes and go through the
fountain head claim like we're going to
look at momentarily and show you have no
clue what you're talking about. You are
pariting the talking point, sir.
Now, we're going to get to that
momentarily, folks. But like I said,
before getting there, I want to look at
some other quotes from this book that I
was quoting from that he claims I'm
completely butchering and has nothing to
do with salvation and Okay.
So what I quoted last week is the
closing sentence of the chapter. It's
what the whole chapter was capped off
with. And it was this actually.
Faith is not certainty of knowledge. It
and then quotes Hebrews here. It is the
substance of things hoped for, the
evidence of things not seen. To obey the
commandments of God is the only way to
obtain his favor. That was the quote
that I quoted that he says I'm taking
out of context. And the phrase in
question is to obey the commandments of
God is the only way to obtain his favor.
And it supposedly has nothing to do with
salvation. Remember this
Jay, you were right. The chapter is
eight pages. The Israelite Exodus is
mentioned and the title is go forward.
Other than that, nothing about your
comment is correct. So what's going on
here folks? Now let me share this
actually.
What's going on here, folks, is she is
using parallelism,
which is a very common thing that she
does.
And you can look this up for yourself,
those that are curious. Testimonies for
the church, volume 4, starting on page
27. So the code for that on the Ellen
White writings website is 4T space 27.1.
She was very regularly across the gamut
of her writings using parallelism, which
is a a common one that we've shown on
the channel before. The analogy that she
loves to use is the Jewish leadership in
Jesus's day with the Christians and
religious leaders of today. So the SDA
church is Jesus in the analogy heralding
the truth, but the Jewish leaders aka us
the Christians are persecuting them for
speaking truth. She uses this for
example in the infamous Christians are
worse than heathens quote. So that's
what's going on here. She's using Moses
and Israel as a parallelism to the SDA
church, which she's using Moses as a
parallel for SDA leadership and SDA
congregants as being the Israelites. And
they are on their exodus to eternal
salvation. Salvation is 100% the context
and I will show that not just from this
chapter, but in a systematic sense
regarding the entire system of SDA
theology because Jay, you are a
slanderer and a liar. You do not know
what you are talking about, sir. So
after talking about Israel in the
Exodus, this is what she is ult this is
this is what she then says quote the
clouds that gather about our way will
never disappear before a halting
doubting spirit. Unbelief says we can
never surmount these obstructions lest
let us wait until they are removed and
we can see our way clearly. But faith
courageously urges in advance hoping all
things believing all things. Obedience
to God is sure to bring the victory. It
is only through faith that we can reach
heaven.
There is great similarity between our
history adventists and that of the
children of Israel. God led his people
from Egypt into the wilderness where
they could keep his law and obey his
voice. The Egyptians who had no regard
for the Lord were encamped close by
them. Yet what was to the Israelites a
great flood of light illuminating the
whole camp and shedding brightness upon
the path before them was to the host of
Pharaoh a wall of clouds making blacker
the darkness of night.
So after the previous six and a half
pages she explains why she was
mentioning Israel in the Exodus. Jay
claims they were already saved. Now it's
just a matter of trust. No sir, because
of your guys' in your guys' assistant
with this analogy, any sort of wavering
on their part would have still resulted
in Pharaoh recapturing them and putting
them back into bondage.
So in your analogy, sin was still on the
heels with the possibility of getting
them
again. The point being, you don't
understand union with Christ and nothing
being able to condemn Christians
anymore. We're already entirely free,
which was my entire point last week if
you would have listened.
But let's continue and this will become
clearer.
So at this time there is a people
whom God has made the depositories of
his law. That's the seventh adventist
church.
To those who obey them the commandments
of God are as a pillar of fire lighting
and leading the way to what?
Eternal salvation.
But to those who disregard them, there
is the clouds of night.
The fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom. Better than all other knowledge
is an understanding of the word of God.
In keeping his commandments, there is
great great reward.
And no earthly inducement should cause
the Christian to waver for the mo sorry.
the Christian to waver for a moment in
his allegiance. Riches, honor, and
worldly pomp are but as dross that shall
perish before the fire of God's wrath.
The obeying isn't about salvation. Jay,
there's no context here of salvation.
She claims the SDA church is the people
entrusted with the law of God in this
generation. And to the people who obey
the ten commandments, they have the
light for the path to eternal salvation.
You're not there yet.
You're on the path.
Nothing about salvation though, right?
The great reward one receives for
obeying the ten commandments is
salvation. Jay,
what is going forward in reference to?
He acted like, "Oh, because I didn't
mention that." She says, "Go forward
repeatedly." That somehow totally
changes the point I was making.
What's it in reference to? The journey
on the way to eternal salvation.
It isn't a completed thing by Christ
where believers are now simply awaiting
the fullness of the promise. The down
payment inheritance that we have in
Christ being fully realized, meaning
resurrection, glorified body, which is
where sin is actually entirely purged.
By the way, the curse lifted off the
creation and so on. We aren't on
probation to see if we'll eventually
make it because God has done what he
can't. Paul says believers are already
seated with Christ in the heavenlies.
the Holy Spirit given as a down payment
of our inheritance, a promise from God
of what we have to look forward to. All
of that is downstream of union with
Christ, which flies in the face of the
parallel she's making here.
There is a general parallel and type in
regards to freedom from bondage and
redemption, etc. But again, like I was
mentioning earlier, lots of great stuff
with the poison subtly slipped in.
Also, this quote implies the SDA church
has the light that leads to eternal
salvation.
God's given them the light that lights
the path. They are the depositories.
Everyone else doesn't have the light for
the path. Total nonsense.
The word is the the path for my feet.
And rightly understanding the law, not
its unlawful use like the Adventist
church has. They have zero business
wielding the law. Unlawful use of the
law in the Adventist church.
Unqualified. They're out there slinging
it around like a sword and causing all
sorts of spiritual damage. The Adventist
teaching on reconciliation does not see
obedience, folks, as a fruit of already
being reconciled to God. It is something
alongside your faith that leads you down
the path toward eventually being
reconciled. So, it is your faith plus
obedience to the Ten Commandments that
get you to eternal salvation.
And no one's able to see how to arrive
at eternal salvation by obeying the
without obeying the Ten Commandments.
It's the pillar of fire lighting the
way, which would mean that how well you
obey the ten commandments will determine
if you're arriving at eternal salvation.
Listen to what she says in her book
here, faith and works.
This is post 1888 and the discussion
around their version of justification by
faith. But notice what she says about
justification. Okay?
Quote, "While God can be just and yet
justify the sinner through the merits of
Christ, no man can cover his soul with
the garments of Christ's righteousness
while practicing known sins or
neglecting known duties. God requires
the entire surrender of the heart before
justification can take place. And in
order for man to retain justification,
there must be continual obedience
through active living faith that works
by love and purifies the soul." What
does Romans 5 1-9 say, Jay? Did you
actually listen to the stream you're
referencing where we camped out in
Romans for almost an hour?
Does Paul explain justification the way
Ellen White did here? Justification's
maintained by your ongoing obedience to
the Ten Commandments. Or did he use
Abraham as an example in chapter 4?
Abraham's obedience was post being
justified. He obeyed because he was, not
as something alongside his faith that
then maintained it.
You guys have the cart before the horse
in your system.
And like I mentioned, this life being a
purgatorial state, this is what I was
referencing. That's what purifies your
soul. It's not going to be a
glorification. That's not going to
change anything.
Justification, now I know that there's
going to be traditions that disagree
with this. We're talking about
Protestantism tonight.
One one's righteous standing before God.
Justification is not strictly on the
basis of Christ's perfect righteousness
alone in this system. Solless
Christristas,
but on Christ's merits plus your faith
in those merits to empower you to be
able to keep the law perfectly. It is a
joint effort by you and Christ.
And it's that joint effort alongside
Jesus that purifies the soul, not Jesus
in his perfect work alone, which is
precisely why I quoted this, the first
quote that I did, Jay, which if you were
listening, you would have caught. We
looked at it earlier. It's the through
the through a door uh through Christ a
door has been opened that quote. Gee,
it's almost like I was quoting things in
a specific order to make a focused point
which was that she did not understand
union with Christ. She she repeatedly
says that Jesus' death opened the door
of salvation making it a possibility for
man and by faith in Christ he'll be
elevated to a position where his
lawkeeping can be found acceptable.
That's not a one-off. She taught this.
She taught that one's justification is
maintained by their actions. What
actions? Obedience to the law. It's your
faith plus obedience to the law that
leads to eternal salvation. You're not
there yet. It's still in limbo. You're
on probation. God wants you to make it,
but ultimately it's on you whether you
do or not. He opened the door, but now
it's on you with his help. So, in
relation to last week's quote, again, I
was quoting these things in an order for
a reason. One was man's faith in Christ
elevates him to a position where his
efforts to keep the law can be accepted.
Then two which is the quote he took
umbrage with was that obedience to the
ten commandments is the only way to earn
God's favor. That was the two points at
that point out of five slides with the
focus being again this woman had no clue
what union in Christ is because if she
understood it she wouldn't say these
things. Now she continues in the last
paragraph. This is the one that he's
taking umbrage with folks.
quote, "The voice of the Lord bidding
his fair faithful ones go forward
frequently tries their faith to the
uttermost, but if they should defer
obedience till every shadow of
uncertainty was removed from their
understanding, and there remained no
risk of failure or defeat, they would
never move on at all." Those who think
it impossible for them to yield to the
will of God and have faith in his
promises until all is made clear and
plain before them will never yield at
all. Faith is not certainty of
knowledge. It is substance of things
hoped for, the evidence of things not
seen. The last sentence, to obey the
commandments of God is the only way to
obtain his favor. Go forward should be
the Christian's watch word.
Ah, so she reiterates what I just
explained. If there's no risk of
failure, people would apparently never
obey, which is totally ridiculous
because again, being united to Christ
frees a person. They have freedom in
Christ. I'm free to live a life pleasing
to Christ. This gets into their faulty
understanding of man. That man's a slave
to sin, a hater of God, cannot do any
good, by nature a child of wrath, cannot
seek for God. It's just over and over
and over. And when God changes the
disposition of a person, that's going to
produce a change in the person. That
change then when they fall and they get
back up and God chastises them, etc.,
They're not losing their justification
be that God perseveres them because he
started something within them. He's a
he's a faithful parent.
I'm free to live a life pleasing to
Christ. That life doesn't maintain
anything. Christ has already
accomplished it.
It happens because of something Christ
is a part has accomplished. That's part
of union. Being a new creature in
Christ. 2 Corinthians 5:17.
There's no risk of failing because
nothing can condemn me. Romans 1 or 8:1.
I have peace with God. Romans 5:1. He's
promised to finish the work that he
started. Hebrews 12:2.
In fact, in Hebrews 12, we were just
there earlier, but back at the beginning
is right after God's saying he's the
author and finisher, author and finisher
of our faith. He then goes on to explain
in Hebrews 12:4-12 that God disciplines
his children when they get out of line.
He doesn't disown a children he's
adopted. He corrects them like a good
parent. They're not on probation to see
if they're going to be disowned.
I know you guys hate that, but it's true
regardless.
Again, she demonstrates the point I was
making. I'm going to keep saying it. She
did not understand union with Christ,
which is why the Adventist church does
not understand union with Christ.
And she finishes it off by exhorting
that obedience to the Ten Commandments
are the only way to earn God's favor.
Well, Jay, regarding justification, she
taught your continual obedience to the
law over time is what maintains your
justification.
That isn't categorically separate
or or or that's that isn't a a a
categorically separate thing that
doesn't propel or sustain your righteous
standing.
It's your obedience alongside your faith
that maintains you on the path to
salvation. But you aren't there yet. You
were elevated to a position where your
lawkeeping can be found acceptable. And
that lawkeeping powered by faith keeps
you on the path with the law being the
light of the path to eternal salvation.
Don't tell me this isn't about
salvation, dude. That I'm a liar and a
deceiver. You're full of it. You didn't
disprove anything. And shame on you for
claiming to be a commandment keeper, yet
you brazenly lie about people and you
have a second commandment violation as
your profile picture.
And now to put the nail in the coffin,
showing that you are way out of your
depths.
You claim that phrase isn't about
salvation. Jay, do you know the fountain
head of that statement and claim that
phrase? She constantly is using the
consistent phrases across the board. You
ever done a systematic study on this
phrase, Jay? Obeying the ten
commandments earns favor with God.
Because we're going to look at the
foundational part of the pre-earth
origin story, the great controversy
narrative. And she's speaking about what
supposedly happened here in heaven after
the fall of man. And Jesus is proposing
a plan of what? Salvation.
Look at the heading.
The plan of salvation. Jay, chapter 4,
Spirit of Prophecy, Volume 1. This is
the beginning here, sir. After the fall
of man. Notice what she says.
Sorrowf filled heaven as it was realized
that man was lost and the world that God
created was to be filled with mortals
doomed to misery, sickness, and death.
And there was no way of escape for the
offender. The whole family of Adam must
die. I saw
the lovely Jesus and beheld an
expression of sympathy and sorrow upon
his countenance. Soon I saw him approach
the exceeding bright light which
enshrouded the father, showcasing her
demoting of Jesus. Oh, she could behold
Jesus but not the father. Said my
accompanying angel, he's in close
converse with his father. The anxiety of
the angels seemed to be intense while
Jesus was commuting with his father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the father. And the
third third time he came from the father
his person could be seen. His
countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and trouble and shown with
benevolence and loveliness such as words
cannot express. He then made known to
the angelic host that a way of escape
had been made for lost man.
He told them that he had been pleading
with his father and he had offered to
give his life a ransom and take the
sentence of death upon himself.
Sorry, I'm moving over to a different
screen here, folks.
And he had offered to give his life a
ransom and take the sentence of death
upon himself that through him man might
find pardon.
That's probation.
that through the merits of his blood and
obedience to the law of God, they could
have favor have the favor of God and be
brought into the beautiful garden and
eat of the tree of life.
What?
What? It's not about salvation.
I'm a liar, Jay. I'm deceiving people.
Have you even read the training wheels
of the SDA system of theology? This is
like SDA theology 101 as it pertains to
the great controversy theme.
Let's read this again. He told them that
he'd been pleading with his father. So
despite the the the division in the
Adventist godhead going on here, which
they claim is what makes them one. It's
not one in being, it's one in mission,
and they're never at cross purposes,
except I guess when it come to the plan
of salvation.
He told him that he'd been pleading with
his father and had offered to give his
life a ransom and take the sentence of
death upon himself that through him man
might find pardon that through the
merits of his blood and obedience to the
law of God they could have the favor of
God
and like they teach it's a return to
Eden that's what salvation is he could
be brought into the beautiful garden and
eat of the tree of life
in the great controversy narrative folks
when man fell Jesus supposedly convened
with the father and tried three
different times to convince him of a
proposed plan of salvation. She says
this in other books, spiritual gifts,
patriarchs and prophets, others. He
pleaded with the father. He insisted
that he'd be the one to come and die for
man so that through him pardon would be
granted. Which if your guys which if
your guys' teaching of probation,
that's what that is their teaching of
probation. And that through faith in
Christ merits plus obedience to the law,
they could what?
What?
Have the favor of God and be brought
back to Eden.
Which is why I had us look at this
quote, Jay, immediately after the quote
you took umbrage with. Again, quoting
things in a specific order, sir. Quote,
"Man who has defaced the image of God in
his soul by a corrupt life cannot by
mere human effort affect a radical
change in himself. He must accept the
provisions of the gospel. What are
those?
He must be reconciled to God through
obedience to his law and faith in Jesus
Christ. His life from then forth must be
governed by a principle. Through
repentance, faith, and good works, he
may perfect a righteous character and
claim through the merits of Christ the
privileges of the sons of God. Close
quote.
He must be reconciled. That's saved. J
through faith in Christ and obedience to
the law.
Not that obeying God is a natural res
natural result of already having been
justified and reconciled. Nope. Faith
plus obedience will result in
reconciliation based on how well you
progress in your lawkeeping. You got to
demonstrate that you're safe to save and
won't let sin possibly jeopardize the
new earth. Like, is this a joke?
Seriously.
Is this a joke?
Phrase isn't about salvation.
It's literally hardcoded in your guys's
plan of salvation.
It's supposedly part of the way that
Jesus proposed to the father for man to
be saved.
But no, no, no, no, no. She wasn't
saying obeying the ten command. I was
trying to stay calm tonight, folks. I
was really trying.
But there's just some times where
Miles is a deceiver. Don't listen to
him. Nah, dude. You're not going to
tarnish our ministry and lie to people.
We're going to show the truth and the
facts. I have no clue what I'm talking
about. I'm twisting the words of God's
messenger. The woman who stated over
seven times to be shown the day and hour
of Christ's return, speaking falsely on
behalf of God, which is a violation of
the third commandment to the highest
degree, by the way, she would have been
stoned in God's economy. The woman who
stated Jesus was exalted to be made
equal with the father, which is a
damnably blasphemous statement of
demoting the Lord Jesus. The woman who
claimed God showed her a cursed false
gospel to infect the world with, leading
millions to predition.
In fact,
like I mentioned earlier, this whole
thing is a knockoff version of the
Mormon plan of salvation.
You can see the Mormon version in Milton
R. Hunters uh the Gospel Through the
Ages book. There's other places. You can
see it on their website, too, but in
that book, he breaks it down. He was a
Mormon leader. Now, look at the
similarities to this and the great
controversy narrative regarding the the
plan of salvation.
Check this out.
First, the Mormon plan of salvation,
which was around before the Millerites,
before Adventism. It is also a extra
biblical mess.
It has a pre-earth origin story
where God desired for his spirit
children to share in his level of glory,
but had to be placed on earth as mortals
first. This gets into their doctrine of
progression and man progressing toward
being gods one day. The plan for this
was based on eternal laws.
Heavenly Father appointed one of his
sons Jesus to be the savior. The savior
was Jehovah from the Old Testament who
lived as a mortal as Jesus and is
Michael the Archangel and is also
referred to as Adam.
Lucifer who is Jesus's brother took
umbrage with this and contested it.
Lucifer was prideful and covetous of
Jesus because Lucifer's plan was to
bring humans back to God with no effort
of their own. So that's a key aspect of
the Mormon message. You have to do your
you're saved by grace through faith
after all you can do. The intro of the
Book of Mormon says
but in this system Jesus's plan had to
had been previously enacted in other
worlds. They believe in all these other
heavenly intelligences.
Lucifer rebelled at the rejection of his
plan and Jesus being accept Jesus's
being accepted leading to him being cast
out and then as Satan.
So there was a council held over this in
heaven and Lucifer was barred from it
and his plan rejected and a bunch of
other stuff. But now compared to the
great controversy narrative, notice the
similarities.
Pre-earth origin story. Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with God the
Father. Jesus was the only being allowed
into the council of God. Lucifer then
became jealous that he wasn't allowed in
the councils and given authority like
Jesus was. Lucifer begins attacking
God's law, claiming God is a
self-seeking and unfair being.
He also claimed evil as a result of
God's doing that God's plan was also
enacted in other worlds is a part of
this. All these other worlds are
watching in sin never entered there and
they're following this plan and that's
why they haven't fallen and
evil is allowed to exist by God to
expose Lucifer in the end and vindicate
God's character. That gets into their
whole thing about why didn't Lucifer
just be get blotted out when when he
sinned. Well, then because it would have
shown all the watching intelligences
that Satan's accusations are right. If
Satan was making these accusations and
then God just destroyed him, it would
have caused the the people who saw that
to think, well, God's not fair then.
Lucifer was right. So, he had to allow
evil to exist to expose Lucifer and then
in the end vindicate his character.
Lucifer's plan was to abolish God's law.
Lucifer claims breaking the law brings
freedom and exaltation. Lucifer starts a
war and is kicked out of heaven and then
becomes Satan. So nine similarities.
There's probably more honestly, but what
are they?
It's an extra biblical pre-earth origin
story provided by the the quote unquote
prophet that's not found in the Bible.
There was a heavenly council held to
figure out the plan. The council was
based on eternal laws. Both Jesus and
Lucifer presented plans. Lucifer was
barred from the council participation.
Jesus is Michael the Archangel. This
plan was in effect in other worlds.
Jesus's plan was accepted because it was
in accordance with God's law. Lucifer
rebels and begins attacking God's God's
plan and law.
So on top of that, Jay, you're not even
familiar with the foundational narrative
of your religion.
You also aren't aware that it's clearly
a borrowed adaptation from Joseph Smith.
And I'd argue both took great influence
from John Milton's Paradise Lost. But
folks, this is why it's hard to take
some of these people seriously.
It is a giant case of projection.
I'm supposedly clueless about SDA
theology, deceiving people. I'm a liar.
And what's said in testimonies volume 4
isn't about salvation. Except she
literally says it's part of the plan of
salvation that Jesus proposed to the
father,
which is that faith in Christ's merits
would grant man probation, elevate him
to a position where his lawkeeping can
be found acceptable, earning favor with
God, leading them to eternal salvation.
And it's obedience to the law that
maintains your righteous standing, aka
justification.
Don't give me that crap. Don't give me
that crap. And don't lie about me
publicly because we're going to correct
it for the record because again, you're
not going to tarnish this ministry and
our efforts. I am not a liar, sir.
Look at how Ellen White defines
sanctification.
Okay?
In conjunction with all of what we've
looked at about all of this, but
including justification earlier, and
remember the chart I showed earlier,
Jesus's merits imparted you gradually
over time, getting you closer and closer
to total sinlessness because no change
is going to happen in character when
Jesus returns. Sons and daughters, page
nine. But look at this. Bible
sanctification is the conformity to the
will of God attained by rendering
obedience to his law through faith in
his son. This isn't part of salvation.
Oh man.
I guess sanctification in their system
is not part of salvation.
Ah same book as earlier but volume four
Jay and again in tandem with this
quote when it is in the heart to obey
God when efforts are put forth to this
end Jesus accepts this disposition and
effect as man's best service and he
makes up for the deficiency with his own
divine merit.
So one meets the righteous requirement
of God by having a disposition. That's a
desire to obey God and then makes his or
her best effort to this end. Jesus then
accepts that effort as a person's best
service and makes up for the deficiency
with his own divine merit gradually over
time.
And this movement wants to claim to be
heirs of the Reformation.
If it wasn't so sad, it might actually
be funny.
This is exactly what I said last week,
Jay. Run the tape back. Nothing I said
last week is in incorrect regarding your
guys' a great controversy salvation
plan. Nothing I said disproves that
Ellen White had zero clue what union
with Christ, meaning salvation, actually
is. She taught an incomplete atonement
of Jesus who was demoted a false gospel
and was a false prophet. Period. But no,
no, no. obedience to the law, earning
favor with God. That's not about
salvation. No, no, no.
So, audience, this is why the loudest
scoffers will not actually come on and
engage. They can't. The true gospel
silences those who come against it. All
they have is character attacks, lies,
and slander.
I mean, this guy hasn't even done the
foundational study of Seventh Day
Adventist systematic theology. But I'm
the deceiver and liar.
Jay, you haven't gone through and
actually done a systematic dig on how
Ellen White used that phrase
consistently across the board. What the
system looks like charted out as a
whole?
I have. Oh, but it's me who doesn't
understand all this, right? I'm not
saying I'm a systematic theology expert,
folks, but I I've read a number of
systematic theologies. I've read the
like I've studied the systematic
theology of this system.
You don't know what you're talking
about, sir. I've said it before and I'll
continue to say it. I did not cheat on
my homework. To use an analogy, I did
not look off my neighbor's paper and
write their answers and then turn my
homework in. I stand by my homework. Do
you? Because it sure doesn't look like
it. Blocking, oh, you're a nasty, vile
person. You're all the excuses.
Especially when you're a part of a
movement that teaches obedience to the
Ten Commandments, earning favor is
literally embedded into the system's
plan of salvation, and yet you claim the
phrase isn't about salvation. I mean,
give me a break. Am
I perfect? Absolutely not. Can I make
mistakes? Absolutely. But no, I'm not a
liar and I'm not a deceiver. You're
simply mad and panic posting. I have all
the screenshots of all your other lies
about me, too.
Some of us actually do care about
seeking to obey God.
But the ones that are the most loud and
ardent about it seem to be the mo the
worst violators.
So if you're going to engage SDA aps
apologetically folks defending the
faith, understand when you start getting
into this territory, you are right over
target. Wear it as a badge of honor and
keep plowing.
The gospel field is ripe for the harvest
in SDA world because it is a spiritual
wasteland, a desert. People's souls are
in utter heat exhaustion trying to
figure out where the heck they're even
going. using the law as a lamp instead
of the word of God and the gospel is
like a giant water stand out in the
spiritual desert. Do not let these types
impede you from the mission. Do not
become distracted. Do not become futile
in these discussions. You know, my
pastor was just preaching on this
actually in First Timothy. And it's like
don't get caught up in these silly
quarrels with these people.
I wanted to do this because I thought
it'd be a good example for other people
to see the sort of claims that these
people will make and just how laughable
it is. I mean, it's just staltifying.
Stalttifying.
The only defense they have, personal
attacks, lies, trying to tarnish me,
etc. They want to destroy me, the
person, not just the teaching. That's
the spirit behind this movement. It can
be traced all the way back to Canrite.
It doesn't matter the approach you take.
Desmond Ford, Dale Ratzlife, EJ Lston,
Rich and Colleen Tinker, Steve Dailyaly,
me. It's always the same narrative with
this movement because they can't own
their actual beliefs and defend them.
So, they'll engage in semantic sufferry
to so desperately appear just like
another Protestant group to have inroads
to try and sheep steal.
The SDA organization is built upon sheep
stealing. It is a sheep stealing
organization. Not going to happen
anymore. Nope. Not going to happen
anymore. Those days are long gone. We
are fortifying the base. We are
strengthening up the church walls. This
is a false gospel. It will lose. Jesus
will put it under his feet. Christ is
king. You guys can focus all your
attention on trying to destroy me. And
we're going to focus on leading people
to Christ and streams of living water
and watch Christ's kingdom flourish. So,
I know that was a lot, folks. It's
already been two hours. I will post the
link for those in the chat right now who
would like to join if there is anyone.
In the meantime, I will go through some
of the comments here and kind of see
what some of you guys have been saying.
I just posted the uh link in the YouTube
chat. I will now do it as well in the
Facebook chat. So, for those that would
like to hop on uh go ahead and you can.
Rodney says, "Miles John 16:8-9. What is
used to convict the world of sin,
judgment, and righteousness? Only the
law reflects these the areas." Yes, this
is a perfect example, Rodney, of you you
can't you you guys don't get it. You you
you're just these are the canned
responses, my man. These are the canned
responses. You're not dealing with the
position. I didn't say anything negative
about the law. I said earlier the
Adventist church has zero business
wielding the law because they don't
understand the proper use of the law as
you are showing right now. If you think
this is now connecting things to saying,
"So therefore, the law is how obedience
to the law is how you're reconciled to
God." I mean, dude,
you're not getting it. Nothing in there.
That's exactly it. Yes, the law convicts
people of sin. That has nothing to do
with being the means alongside faith
that reconciles someone to God. That's
precisely the problem. Sir, join. Stop
barking in the comments. You do this
every stream. And I don't want to block
you, but it's like, dude, listen to
what's actually being said, please. Stop
with the the straw man and the
characters. You guys are so used to
dealing with Antonyomians that you just
you're not even able to deal with
people. Um, so let's see
what else do we have on here.
Yeah, here you are. Jay, you didn't show
the picture, the comparison of what you
quoted and what Ellen White said in
Testmay Volume 4. You didn't show both
pictures and I was referring to Tesm's
volume four. Read the who? Yeah, you're
you're clueless, dude. You've already
been silenced. You're going to be
ignored.
All right.
Yeah, read the whole article, Jay. I
have read the whole article, sir. That
That's the problem. You assume that
people haven't actually done the
digging. How's about you join and stop
being a coward and actually come have a
discussion face to face and not shoot
spitballs from the sidelines, but you
won't because the gospel silences you.
You don't want to defend your guys'
gospel. You want to fly under the radar
and tell everyone else that you have the
the most important message for this
time. Oh man. But you won't come on a
platform and publicly defend it. Oh,
because you're mean. Oh, because you're
this. Your prophet has told you, who
cares if that's the case? You're
supposed to ignore that. You're supposed
to be able to come in and show a gentle
spirit. And that'll be what compels
people to say, "Oh, wow. What do they
have? Give me a break. Give me a break.
You don't know what you're talking
about, buddy." As we saw, the plan of
salvation, chapter 4, yes, it is about
salvation. It's literally part of the
plan of salvation. Stop trying to argue.
Own it. Repent of your lies, sir. Get
rid of your Second Commandment violation
profile picture while you're at it.
Let's see what else do we have. Anybody
else in chat here? If no one's going to
hop on, I apologize folks for um how
long it went, but I wanted to address
those things, have them on record. This
will not be the last one of these. So,
um hold fast in in understanding that uh
we will we will definitely be back. It
looks like our friend Jason from last
week is here. So, let's bring our friend
Jason in. Uh, might be the only guest
here tonight, Jason, just because we're
getting a little late and I can't go for
three hours like last time. And so, with
that said, welcome, sir. So, Jason, you
are back. You were here last week. Let's
hear your best case, sir, for the
Adventist system of theology being the
gospel that was revealed by Jesus Christ
to the apostles.
further. Oh,
what I'd really like to get into though
since it's downstream of that um is for
you to explain for us um the Adventist
Jesus and uh where in scripture you can
show us for example that Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with the
father. This is part of the the whole
plan of salvation and all that stuff.
So, are you able to show us that
somewhere from scripture?
If given enough time, I probably could,
but I was coming on tonight with
intention to sort of answer a couple of
things you said during the talk show and
also to really like dig more into the
gospel and our understanding of the
gospel and to address some of the claims
that you made concerning what Ellen said
about how the gospel seems almost
synergistic with certain quotes that you
used. And I wanted to share some quotes
that sort of paint a different picture.
Well,
but of of course, you know, starting
from the Gospels.
Well, so you can set up a time to come
and do that specifically. We did this
last week and then see what happens is
we get way off track and then we're not
able to dig in enough on the topic. So,
for example, we went to uh last week
once saved always saved got brought up.
Well, the plan wasn't to talk about
covenant theology because that's really
what that's downstream of. And then
we're only able to touch on it um in
passing. And then I get people emailing
me about that now and going on and on
and on and it's like well you don't
understand. I was trying to be
respectful and bring people or or like
respect people's time and that sort of
stuff and and their comments but we end
up getting off of the point of tonight
which is the Adventist church the
proposition on changing the mind is the
Adventist church has a false god and a
false gospel. So, what was presented
tonight, happy to hear your comments on
that, but I would love to hear how the
everlasting gospel, which the Adventist
church, we saw, we showed the
documentation, all sorts of things that
are not what the apostles were preaching
as the gospel like we saw in Ephesians
chapter 1. So, I'd love to hear how this
Well, really, this Jason,
there you go. That's that's the
everlasting gospel in a nutshell. So, I
would love to hear where any of this
stuff is the gospel.
This was the stuff I mentioned tonight.
Okay. Are you able are you able to show
are you able to show us that this is
this is the gospel?
To be fair, this is an interesting
starting point because, you know, as I
think I mentioned last time, the way I
structure my theology and yes, Grant and
I am an Adventist, but I always start
with the foundation of God is love and
then I work my way out from there
because I think that's how all Christ
centered doctrine ought to be. Oh,
that has nothing that Jason Jason,
I don't want to be rude, buddy, but it's
getting late here, so I want I do want
to get to the point. That's all
obfuscation. I'm not just starting here.
I've been going for my my throat's
getting sore, man. I've been going for
two and a half hours. I didn't just
start here. We looked at it earlier.
Your church claims this is the
everlasting gospel. I showed quote after
quote after quote after quote after
quote that this and and you're saying
the same thing Robert Fulenberg said.
Well, we need to start, of course, with
the love of God. And that, yeah, the
cross of Christ is the foundation,
but then this is on top of it. You have
to have this. This is the message for
salvation. This is the message, sir.
I don't get why you guys do the I'm
sorry, but like I don't get why you guys
do these games.
Own up to what you believe. Own up to
what you believe and stop with the with
the Well, it's it's weird to start here.
No, sir. The challenge is that Paul
preached a gospel message to the people
at Ephesus. That message was the power
of God to salvation. They heard the
message. They believed and they were
saved and given the spirit as a down
payment of the inheritance in Christ.
Show us that what Paul told them was the
investigative judgment to leave apostate
Protestantism, seventh day Sabbath
observance, health message, Ellen
White's writings in the spirit of
prophecy, the state of the dead, sinless
perfectionism, young earth creationism.
Show us this.
Don't just obuscate. Don't tell me,
"Well, you're not really understanding
it." Yes, I am. We just looked at the
sources. Your own official organ, the
Advent review, is saying this is the
everlasting gospel.
Show us this.
Which, okay, I'm fine with doing that,
but to clear the air, I'm not trying to
obuscate. I'm trying to communicate to
you how I do theology. You know,
Jason, I don't care about how you do
theology. This is about the Adventist
church as an organization, not your own
personal opinion.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. So,
when it comes to explaining certain
things to people, especially in an
audience like this, right, where there
are so many different people from many
different walks of life, different
denominations, backgrounds, everything
like that. Um, I don't think it's
the most prudent
course of action to start with things
that are more on the contentious sides
of things, which I'm fine to sit down
with you and explain these point by
point by point.
I don't need Jason, I don't need you to
explain them to me. I know the
teachings, my man.
Yeah, but you're not listening. No,
you're No, you're not listening.
I'm I'm trying to answer. You'd asked me
to explain to you how this is part of
the everlasting gospel, right?
No. Explain to us that this is the
gospel. See, you're assuming the
everlasting gospel like earlier with
with Herbert Douglas, that the
everlasting gospel is different than the
gospel. No, it isn't. It's the same
thing that Paul's talking about in
Ephesians 1. The everlasting gospel is
the gospel. Adding everlasting to the
front of it doesn't make it a different
message.
That's the whole point. I don't know if
you got here for the whole thing, but
that's literally what the whole point of
what Herbert Douglas was getting at is
that the gospel is quote unquote a
limited gospel. Your scholars don't
agree with you. They would say that what
I'm proclaiming tonight is only a
limited gospel. The everlasting gospel
is a restoration of the fullness of the
gospel restored. So, please show us this
in scripture that any of these things
are the power of God to salvation. That
if you believe this, this is the power
of God to salvation.
Not personal opinion. This is about the
organization. I said the SDA church has
a false gospel. Not your own personal
take in your own personal opinions. The
Adventist organization. We looked at
official sources tonight, not just Joe
Schmo.
Can you do that? It should be easy, my
man. Like the gospel is not complicated.
And that kind of shows the the purpose.
You should be able to point us to where
this is what is explained as being the
message that is the power of God to
salvation. If you're going to be a
prepared people and this has to be this
is this is the message the most
important message being heralded in all
of the world at any time ever given
is this.
Show us that sir. I I'll give you plenty
of time to to talk, but please do not
just I I want to stay on topic. Don't
jump over into like, well, synergism and
that's not the gospel. People that
disagree with me. I was not always a
monarchist after leaving Adventism.
There's this narrative out there that,
oh, well, if you refute reformed
theology, that automatically vindicates
Adventism. No, there's people in this
audience that are not reformed. There's
people in this audience that don't
believe eternal security. We have the
same gospel message.
I just told you earlier as well if you
were if you were here Ephesians 1 you or
Philippians one united in one mind
around the gospel. It doesn't matter if
somebody's a I don't care if somebody's
a Baptist. You know how many pe how many
Presbyterians have been on my platform
and I'm a Presbyterian. Zero.
Zero.
Yet we have the same gospel.
I don't care if they're a Baptist or
non-denominational
because we have the same gospel. That's
what I'm trying to explain to you guys.
And I'm I'm getting a little worked up
like this because I want it to really
sink in. You seem like a really nice
guy. You seem sincere and you seem
genuine. So, I'm not saying that you're,
you know, you're not a genuine person or
any of that, but I would love for you to
explain how the everlasting gospel is a
different gospel than what the apostles
were preaching.
Yeah. So, this is where I would disagree
that it's a different gospel because
Paul clearly says, I believe it's
Galatians chapter 3, that the gospel was
preached to Abraham.
I agree. It's the same gospel. Yes,
there's one gospel message.
So, he preached investigative judgment,
leave apostate Protestantism, seventh
day Sabbath observance, health message.
This is what was preached to Abraham.
That's not what I said. I said,
"Okay,
this is your gospel, Jason. This is your
guys's gospel."
And you said the gospel is the same and
it's been preached to Abraham and you're
using the same language that was used in
that review and herald paper. It was
preached to Abraham and Noah, but it
looked different for that time, right?
It wasn't these teachings. That's a
different gospel.
I I don't know how to make that any more
clear. I don't understand how how that's
hard to to grasp.
Where would you point to in scripture,
Jason, to show me that? Not don't just
go to Revelation 14 and say, "Well, see,
there's the three angels, so therefore
it is all this."
No, no. Show me in the Bible where any
person, this was the message that was
being preached to them. That was the
power of God to salvation. A person
believes it. And we're talking about
true belief here. We're not talking
about just check. I'm we're in this
hypothetical. A person truly believes.
They're given the spirit as a down
payment of the inheritance that they
have by being in Christ, united to
Christ, which has all sorts of benefits
that come with it. That has nothing to
do with young earth creationism, my man.
That has nothing to do with a person
believing there's modern prophets and
that Ellen White is the spirit of
prophecy or conditional immortality. I
don't care what you believe about the
afterlife. I care about what you believe
about the gospel because if you don't if
you're not correct on the gospel, you're
going to go to the bad place afterlife.
So, I don't care what you believe about
it. It's it's going to be terrible
regardless of if you think it's real
flames, fake flames, forever, not
forever. That's not the gospel. None of
that is the gospel. So, I would love for
you to show me. I'm serious. I would
love for you to show me how this
everlasting gospel is different than the
gospel that the apostles were preaching.
like your official church's statements
say such that the everlasting gospel
being different is not a cursed gospel
that Paul says in Galatians 1 6-9.
Right? So
I'm not going to say it's different in
terms of what the gospel is supposed to
accomplish, which is the salvation of
fallen men.
But based on what Jesus says in John 16,
and we don't have to turn there, I'm
just going to quote. So in John 16,
Jesus says something very basic but
profound. He says, "I have many things
yet to tell you, but you cannot bear
them now." So I believe that it's this
way when it comes to the gospel and the
individual that when truth comes into
somebody's heart,
that person has
the choice to either accept that truth
or reject that truth. And since truth is
transmitted by, you know, information,
experience, etc.,
It's going to take time for someone to
gain full access to
what the truth is. But according to what
we know in the Bible, since God has set
the habitations of, you know, where we
live so that we have basically I'm
paraphrasing like loosely paraphrasing.
Yeah.
Yeah. He set the bounds of our
habitation so we in my words have the
best possibility of being saved so that
we could you know reach after him feel
after him. That's why you have you know
people like Cornelius who are still
considered to be you know God's
children.
So that being said,
I think it's it's very important to
realize that
the gospel will unfold to the person and
each person has the information that
they need to
and like I said when truth comes to them
they either need to accept that truth or
reject that truth. I'm thinking
particularly in Romans chapter 2. Um you
know how in Romans chapter 2 it talks
about the Gentiles who I believe it says
something like they obey the gospel um
and they show like the
the tr the evidence of the truth because
the law was written in their heart and
they do this um apart from
apart from I believe it's the law. Um, I
got to look it up again. But Romans
chapter 2 is basically what I'm trying
to say that a person can be like a
Cornelius or a person can, you know,
live somewhere in the Amazon and may
have not
had, you know, the type of information
that we have today here in America. But
if they accept the truth that they know
according to Romans chapter 2,
no doesn't say that. It doesn't say
they'll be saved just based on the
that
continue. Continue. I'm just saying
Romans 2 is that's not the context of
Romans 2. Paul's explaining to Jews that
Gentiles are in essentially this the
same boat as they are even though they
were the ones given the law, etc. But
continue.
Yeah. So, I was just bringing up Romans
chapter 2 to show
Sorry about that. I was bringing up
Romans chapter 2 to show
[Music]
that the nature of the truth that we
have
it's basically
how would I say it I I can't think of a
better word than like unfolding in
nature like you know just like a child
grows and doesn't learn you know ABC's
the very day that they're born like so
it is with understanding the you
matchless charms of Christ and the depth
of knowledge of the gospel. Like it it
takes time to unfold and this is why I
said it's a little
uncomfortable for me to sort of
immediately answer some of your
propositions because the gospel is a
deep topic. It takes time to unpack.
Like I I feel comfortable with sharing
Jason.
Jason Jason. Okay.
You're not answering. Yeah, I I did
because we have other people in Q and
it's been two and a half hours and I
want to be respectful to them as well
and bring them in. So, as the host, I I
need to step in because you're not
answering the question. You're you're
giving us the the the runaround. Again,
you're a nice guy. I don't think that
you're doing it maliciously, etc. You
are not answering the proposition.
You're not you because you can't. That's
the reality. The fact that you're saying
the gospel is complicated, Jason. This
is the foundation of the Christian
faith. It doesn't. The gospel does not
change as you mature in the faith. And
you're like, "Oh, wow. The things on the
slide right now compromise the
foundational aspect of the gospel." So,
you're saying, "Well, people will evolve
and eventually be off of what the
initial gospel message is.
This is not the gospel. This isn't the
gospel. This is not the gospel. Period.
It can't be demonstrated from
scripture." I just had up on the screen
as well. Listen, Jason. Listen to the
word of God. Ask yourself, did the
people here that were listening to this,
this original audience, the body of
churches in Ephesus, did they have this
same complicated understanding that
you're you're having? In him, we have
obtained an inheritance, having been
predestined according to the purpose of
him who works all things according to
the counsel of his will, so that we who
were the first to hope in Christ might
be to the praise of his glory. in him
union with Christ. You also when you
heard the word of truth.
What is that? The gospel of your
salvation.
So these Christians that he's writing to
are people who heard the message. The
gospel and believed in what? Him.
Because the gospel is coming from Jesus
Christ and it's about the person and
work of Jesus. When doing so, they were
sealed with the promised Holy Spirit,
who is the guarantee of our inheritance
until we acquire possession of it to the
praise of his glory. It is not
complicated, sir. It's not complicated.
That's the concern we have for you guys.
When you say that the gospel is
complicated, you have zero business
discussing esquetology then.
Yeah.
You guys love esquetology, yet you think
the gospel is complicated.
Yeah. I don't think at any time did I
say the gospel was complicated. I was
saying that the gospel unfolds and we
grow in our understanding of the gospel.
Yeah.
Because as an understanding in the
gospel,
yeah, I don't think there's anything
wrong with that statement because of
what it says in Ephesians chapter 3.
In Ephesians chapter 3, Paul talks about
how the gospel is or rather the love of
God which is you know embedded in the
gospel is broad and deep. you know, the
length, the depth, the height, the
width. The love of Christ which passes
knowledge. This is what I'm trying to
tap into. And that's part of the gospel.
It's the love of Christ.
Yeah. That has nothing to do, Jason,
with believing the investigative
judgment, the sanctuary, leaving
apostate Protestantism, 7th day Sabbath
observance, etc.
Okay.
It has nothing to do with any of that.
I do believe it does, but we don't have
time to explain it. This is why I was
trying to tell you I I wouldn't want to
start with
this checklist because you have to start
with the love of God and then as you
unfold as you
dive deep into the love of God all of
these beautiful truths come into picture
come into focus.
No they don't because they completely
contradict being in united to Christ.
Jason,
we just talked about justification and
sanctification in the system in
comparison to
the the true gospel,
right?
This stuff is not the gospel message.
It's not the power of God to salvation.
I don't understand how you guys can't
see it.
This is exactly what I was saying about
it's a spiritual wasteland where you
guys are navigating through and saying,
"Well, it's this complicated thing that
evolves over time as you grow in your
understanding." No. No, it isn't. At no
time did I say it was complicated. At no
time did I say it was complicated.
I know J I'm I'm I'm just sorry. I'm not
repeating verbatim what you're saying.
But you did. You said the go
but that's very important because if
you're claiming that I'm saying the
gospel is complicated. That's not what
I'm saying. I I said the gospel is deep.
It's profound.
No.
Paul says that it's the height and
length and depth
and you know the breath of the love of
Christ that's in the gospel.
We we'll run the tape back Jason. But
you you the reason I had that response
is cuz you you claimed that this subject
is not just a succinct simple thing.
It's this complicated thing like the
guest last week who had to go into all
this sanctuary stuff and just and it's
all coming from a place of well you just
don't understand the love of God then oh
you just haven't really advanced and
you're like I'm not saying that you're
saying that Jason but that is what you
guys are saying. If you don't see all
this stuff, well, you're just not
advancing or understanding the love of
God and yada yada. Jason, I I appreciate
you. Like I said, I do want to get to
some of the other guests that are here.
I want to be respectful of that. It's
already 2 hours 37 minutes, so we don't
have a super long time, but come back to
the next one of these. Again, this will
not be the last one. We can have more
discussion. It'd probably be better for
you though if you want to have a
specific discussion about something
specific um to email. go to answering
adventism.com and just go to the contact
uh contact us and
send over a message and we can we can
have a more formal because this I want
it to be focused on specifically this
task. I want to see the evidence and the
proof of this and so I appreciate you
like I said you're you're a nice guy so
any final words that you have and then
I'm going to move on to the next guest.
Yeah, one final thing I'm going to post
it in the queue here. Um, just if you
could read this quote cuz I wanted to
share this with you as you're reading
some of the Ellen White quotes where
you're talking about justification and
sanctification. I feel like this
particular quotation nails all of that
ukulele.
Jason, the the I've I've only heard this
shtick probably 2,000 times. I know she
said that here, but look what she says
over here. Um, that's again part of the
problem because she said that she never
wrote a sentence of heresy. that all of
her words that she wrote were coming
from the throne room of God, that her
words are barricaded by a thus sayeth
the Lord um and so on and so forth.
We've demonstrated that um at infinitum
in the Ellen White funeral stream. If
you haven't seen that, I suggest
checking going check it out. You can say
it's all out of context or whatever.
That's fine. But uh the the point is is
that
pointing to a statement where it's like,
well, over here she says this. I said
earlier in the presentation that
oftentimes she'll say lots of great
things depending on who she's stealing
from and she'll say all sorts of great
stuff and then poison pill is just
subtly slipped in. So
you just just pointing to somewhere else
and saying oh well she says this over
here so well that doesn't deal with the
plethora of the problematic quotes.
That's why we're quoting the problematic
ones. I'm not saying that every single
word that she wrote is because again,
she's oftentimes taking from and and
we'll use the term literary borrowing
from sound biblical teachers. So that
that's not going to work wi with me
because it doesn't change the facts of
what she said. You maintain your
justification by your behavior. That's
and you guys are not Protestant. So So
stop with that shtick. Your guys' view
is not Protestant. They want to ride the
coattail of the reformers when it comes
to the law and and these sorts of
things. But then when it comes to the
nature of man, oh now we want to jump
over to the John Wesley platform or
firmly in the Armenian lane, Jud Lake
used to always say in class and it's
like, dude, stop with that. Stop with
that. You guys are your own unique
thing. So I appreciate you, man. And I'm
going to bring uh the next guest on. So
again, yeah, no problem. Thank you.
All right, guest. Next guest, Joel. Same
proposition for you. Let's hear your
best case for the Adventist system
theology being the gospel that was
revealed by Jesus Christ to the
apostles. But better yet, explain to us
uh where in scripture it says that Jesus
Christ was exalted to be made equal with
the father. Since it's his gospel, if we
have the wrong Christ, you're definitely
going to have the wrong gospel.
Uh can you hear me, sir? Because you are
in studio.
Your mic is unmuted, but we can't hear
you.
Nope. Can't hear you, buddy. Okay, I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring in the next our
next guest because
you can't be heard, sir. Sorry.
All right, the baseball lover, are you
there? You are back. Welcome back again,
friend. How are you?
Greetings. Hello, friend.
Yeah, definitely. So, same same
Let's Let's bring me back in. Okay. I'm
not doing it on purpose. I just A little
disclaimer.
Huh? I I didn't hear you. What' you say
there?
If I'm getting off topic, just bring me
back in. I'm not doing it on purpose.
Yeah. No, no, no. You're You're good.
Just again, same proposition. Let's hear
your best case for the Adventist system
of theology being the gospel that was
revealed by Jesus Christ to the
apostles. But better yet, that Jesus
Christ was exalted to be made equal with
the father because it's his gospel. And
so if you have the have a false Christ,
you're necessarily going to have a false
gospel as well.
Okay.
Um let's hear from the mouth of Jesus
himself.
Okay.
Because you said the apostles. Um let's
go straight to Jesus. Luke chapter 10.
Okay. Luke chapter 10. What verses?
right before the parable of the good
Samaritan. I believe that's Luke 10
chapter. Yeah, chapter 10 verse 20.
Uh what's on my internet?
I might have to get a manual Bible.
Well, I have it I have it brought up
here. Are you talking about verses 23? I
I believe it starts in 23. Um the young
rich a young it's not the rich young
ruler. A lawyer comes to Jesus.
Okay.
And he says, "What must I do to inherit
eternal life?"
Uh oh. Okay.
Uh oh, no. Verse 26.
25. Sorry. There you go. 25. A lawyer
stood up to test him, saying, "What
shall I do to inherit eternal life?" And
Jesus points him towards the law. And
then Jesus said in verse 28,
you have answered correctly. Do this and
you will live. So straight from the
mouth of Jesus, you have to obey the law
to inherit eternal life.
Okay, continue reading.
This isn't Ellen White. This is Jesus.
Yep. Keep reading.
Uh sure. Who is my neighbor? Um
uh seeking to justify himself. He said,
"Who is my neighbor?" Jesus replied, "A
man was going down from Jerusalem." Oh.
And then and then he gives a parable of
the good Samaritan.
I don't you want me to read all that or
just paraphrase? Most people
Well, well, a couple things. So, you're
essentially saying, well, see, Jesus
says to keep the law is to to be saved.
So, what thing on our our list here?
Where in any of this is that the the
gospel message of the power of God to
salvation?
Because we could get into well because
we could get into
well we could get into all this right
right now but G if you think that Jesus
is laying out the the sotiological
uh pathway here that oh it's just you do
the law and you'll be saved there's
nothing here about faith that should be
your indicator that Jesus is not talking
so teologically
Jesus has something else going on here
and if you look at the par the parallel
of this you get more information about
what's going on here Jesus was pointing
out to this individual the specific
problem that was in his own life.
He's not teaching that the gospel is do
the law and you'll be saved. But even if
that were the case, none of that's in
the law.
So, can you show us that this is the
gospel message that was preached by the
apostles, revealed by Jesus Christ, and
is the power of God to salvation? That's
what the Bible says, that the gospel is
the power of God to salvation. The
believers in Ephesus heard the message,
the word of truth, the gospel of your
salvation. When they believed in him
after hearing the message, because it's
about believing in the correct Christ
and his person and work that he is who
he says he is. He did what he said he
would do. He did it a successfully. You
can't make it. You need Christ. You're a
sinner. So, I turn and believe that he
is who he says he is. In response, the
Holy Spirit born again, given as a down
payment, seal deposit. That's the
foundation of the gospel. That's the
gospel in a in a nutshell there.
Where is is any of this stuff part of
the gospel message?
Okay. All that stuff that you mentioned,
the sealing of the Holy Spirit, um the
the all of that, none of that is me
mentioned in one passage.
You got the multiple passages.
Let's put the the I didn't say you said
that. I'm just You're saying that's the
essence of the gospel. You're you're
taking yourself several doctrines and
you're putting them together and saying
this is the fullness of the gospel.
Yeah. Right here. Right. Right here,
buddy. This is what we started with. Did
you see the beginning of the stream?
Yeah. I saw portions of the beginning
and then I had to step out and um
Okay. Well, at the very beginning, I
said here it is with scriptural
landmarks.
Absolutely. Just to show just to show
this is where across the board the the
gospel message this is the gospel
message and the root of it is first and
you said this last week 1 Corinthians 15
1-4
that's the the the gospel in a nutshell
and what comes with that union with
Christ which is what we talked about
last week. So in here is the benefits
that we find in scripture about being
united to Christ. So no this isn't me
just making my own fullness of the
gospel. I'm just compiling together the
gospel message is about the person and
work of Jesus. The good news about the
kingdom of Christ being here. Something
you guys don't believe. You think it's
it's something off in the future. But
that the Messiah's kingdom is here. What
that means is that he has established
his kingdom defeating death, defeating
death, uh, Satan, the grave, sin, etc.
So man can be reconciled to God. That's
the good news. This is it laid out. This
isn't me just making my own fullness of
the the gospel. And I didn't say that
you had to stick to just one single
passage. I was just pointing to
Ephesians 1 because that's where we were
earlier. But show me anywhere in
scripture, sir. Where all of these or
any of these have anything to do with
the power of God to salvation?
Where do I have to adhere to the health
message? And that that's and that's the
power of God to salvation because in
your system it's necessary because well
it's a return to the Eden diet and you
have to demonstrate that you're going to
be fit for the new earth. That's why
it's in there. It's not because oh you
just hear this and it's no it's a part
of your message of salvation. It's the
right arm of the gospel. Show us where
the health message is part of the
gospel. It's the power of God to
salvation.
Okay.
So all these doctrines you're stating
that
we teach that you have to believe these
nine specific doctrines in order to be
saved. That these nine doctrines
together create the go what we believe
is the gospel. Is that your
this is just this is just a listed down
list of them for people to see what all
is entailed in your everlasting gospel.
It's more than this. We just looked at
the source earlier from the review and
herald.
Yes. This is your guys's message. This
is your guys's message of of the
everlasting gospel. It's what one has to
adhere to to be a prepared people.
And
the claim is if you reject creationism.
Sure. Um
Okay. Well, the the
basically I was talking about number
seven and I quoted Jesus himself and I I
feel like we got over that very quickly.
Um,
where does Jesus say to the rich where
did Jesus say to the rich young ruler
that if he is sinlessly perfect he will
uh
yeah he told him
that that doesn't and so okay then sir I
don't know what your name is the
baseball lover so what about all the
other groups that that claim that same
thing is that enough
they don't have the three angels message
the most important message for this time
they don't have spirit of prophecy the
mark of the remnant church etc there's
lots of groups out there that teach that
same thing that you guys are claiming
that it's by keeping the law that you're
saved. Are they fine? Are they saved?
They go to church on Sunday.
Oh, they're not keeping the law. Right.
If if Christians live in sin and they
don't keep the law, then do they truly
believe in Jesus? Tr
sir, are you are you keeping are you
keeping the law?
I am absolutely.
You are. So, you're without sin.
You have you have no you have no sin in
your life right now.
I do not lust after other women, only my
wife.
Um, and I'm following the teachings of
Jesus. And
my man, that is not See, you don't
understand the standard, which is what
I'm trying to essentially lead you to.
Sure.
You think you think you're without sin?
Absolutely. No.
Okay. Well, you're Well, you're Well,
you're a liar. Yeah. You're Well, you're
a liar. First John tells you you're a
liar. So, you're deceiving yourself. You
you don't understand how high the bar
is. You've created a law in your own
image. You think it's, oh, I'm not
lusting after other women. Oh, I'm not
bowing down to statues. Those are the
sort of things people typically think
when they say these things. You don't
understand the root of the issue. You
put nothing in your life today above the
above God. Anything at any point in any
thought, word, deed, or motive today,
you put nothing before God in your life
today.
That's idol. That's idolatry. Idolatry
is putting anything else before God in
your life. It's not just bowing down to
statues, for example.
So today, you loved God perfectly with
every thought, word, deed, and motive
and didn't put anything in any of those
categories.
By the power of the Holy Spirit, yes.
Yeah. You're you're deceiving yourself.
You're deceiving yourself.
Jesus Jesus told us to obey the law so
that we will have life in eternal life.
So that I imag Jesus talked about
eternal life. You said it's not a
siological passage, but Jesus said
because it's not.
You need to look at the parallel.
You need to look at the
Yeah, you you need to look at the
parallel again. I already mentioned that
because the passage isn't teaching you
sotiology. That's not the that's not the
purpose of what's going on in that
passage. That's not why Jesus was saying
that.
You need to look at the parallel. You
need to look at the parallel. Jesus was
making a point. He's he mentions nothing
about faith. So you don't have to have
faith. You just keep the law. He doesn't
mention faith, buddy.
You're missing it. You You went away
from clear didactic passages like the
episttolary literature which does lay
out these things so teologically and you
jump to somewhere else which all groups
love this. Are we going to jump to James
2 next?
All these groups they use the same
passages in the same verses.
I could say that about you.
I'm sure you could. passages. You use
use the same passages and and you I see
you reference Paul a lot. Paul wasn't
the original 12 and so
Okay. So now we have the downplaying of
Paul. I was waiting for that. You guys
hate Paul's literature. Of course you're
one of these Judaizers typically hate
Paul. You are deceiving you're deceiving
yourself, sir. You are deceiving
yourself. You think you're without sin.
John calls you a liar and you are
deceiving yourself. So you you you're
you don't understand the the height and
the the depth of sin and just how deep
the the chasm is, John.
And I hope that God will take the the
blinders off. The standard is not trying
your best.
You're essentially saying that you have
a character like Jesus. You have a
perfect character like Christ.
My my best alone absolutely will not
meet that standard. I am in agreement
with
Right. But but but your faith in Christ
merits making up the Yeah. the
difference.
Now, because I believe and I have the
Holy Spirit, he does bring perfection
into our lives. And you mentioned call
me a liar because of John.
John said, "Okay, first
well, start at 1 John 18." No, start at
1 John 18. You did this last time.
Yeah. Yeah. You You did this last time.
You jumped to the middle of the epistle,
skipping what he's previously said,
which is more than likely a homalytic
epistle where it was being preached as a
sermon. And I told you last week when
you brought this up or no no yeah I
think it was you. It was one of the
people or maybe it was Jason that
brought up that in 1 John 1:3 he talks
about the love of God and all of that
but of course you want to jump to first
John. So what do you want to do? 1 John
2 3 through4 as well. Now by this we
know that we know him. If we keep his
commandments he says I know him and
doesn't keep his commandments as a liar
and the truth isn't in him. Is that
where you want to jump next?
I wasn't going there but I mentioned
John.
Yeah I'm I'm super familiar with first
You moved to Paul. I I was mentioning
Jesus and you moved to Paul. No, I
explained to you that Jesus is not
laying out sotiology. That's what I
said. I didn't ignore what Jesus is
saying. And then I told you to look at
the parallel in the the parallel passage
out of Luke.
The rich
Jesus clearly didn't have the same view
that you do because Jesus taught his
disciples to pray in the same book. You
want to you want to go there? Two
chapters prior Jesus teaching his
disciples how to pray. What does he say?
Is this a parable passage by the way?
Are you talking?
No, I'm showing you this first, but the
parallel is over in Matthew. What does
Jesus say when teaching his disciples
how to pray?
What does Jesus say?
So Jesus has the same view you have
apparently that oh, if you keep the law,
he doesn't mention anything about faith.
So just keeping the law, that will do
it. You don't have to have faith because
he didn't tell that guy anything about
faith. But he's laying out sotiology.
He's laying out sotiology because
there's nothing there about faith,
right? What does he tell his disciples
when how to pray? Now Jesus was praying
in a certain place. And when he
finished, one of his disciples said to
him, 'Lord, teach us to pray as John
taught his disciples. And he said to
them, "When you pray, say, 'Father,
hallowed be your name. Your kingdom
come. Give us each day our daily bread
and forgive us our sins.
For we ourselves forgive everyone who is
indebted to us, and lead us not into
temptation." Yet Jesus had this view of,
"Yeah, you're supposed to be sinlessly
perfect, but I'm going to teach you a
daily prayer that you're supposed to
pray where you're supposed to ask for
forgiveness."
Jesus is showing the posture that the
Christian takes, not an attitude of not.
You just told us you were sinless. You
just said earlier sinless through the
perfecting work of the Holy Spirit and
that you had no conscious sin throughout
your whole day today. As if that
summarizes it all. You don't even
understand that there are sense of
omission, not doing things you should be
doing. You think the entire day today
you didn't have a single thought where
you put anything before God in your
thought, word, or deed. My friend, yes,
you you're you're deceived. You're
deceived. And this is why you don't
understand the gospel. Because if you
understood the gospel without all this
other other stuff added in and just
getting bogged down. It's so hard for
Adventists to see the simple gospel, you
would understand why the gospel is
actually good news.
1 Corinthians 15, the simple gospel.
Jesus.
Yeah. not what you guys are teaching.
Your own scholars just said that's a
limited gospel.
You said that you watched the stream.
Did you see the sources?
That's not the fullness of the gospel.
My man a lot of different directions. So
that's
No, I'm I'm running it back to Jesus. I
I was really trying to bring it back to
Jesus. Um and then So
And who is Jesus? Who is Jesus? You've
avoided that as well.
Jesus is the son of God.
Was he exalted to be made? Was he
exalted to be made equal with the
father?
Exalted to be made. Yes, of course.
Okay. You have a false Christ. You don't
you don't even know Christ. So don't
point to Jesus Christ and try and tell
us you're going to tell us about Christ.
Exalted to be made equal with the
father.
That's the Yes. Would you like the
quote?
You're okay. And you're saying that is a
false gospel. No, I'm saying it's a
false Christ, which is going to produce
a false gospel. Because if you have a
false Christ and the gospel is Jesus
Christ, you're going to have a false
gospel and a false Christ.
Would you like the quote?
Yeah. Yeah. Give me the quote. I I
didn't I
Well, no. I'm just I'm just gonna I'm
just going to bring it up that
Yeah. Yeah. Bring it up.
Jesus. You don't We Christians believe
in the ascension. Protestants believe
this is sir. This is prior to the
creation of the earth. The earth isn't
even created yet, sir, in your guys'
narrative. This is part of the pre-earth
origin story. It's what started your
great controversy. Are you not aware of
this?
What started the great controversy?
Satan becoming jealous of what?
The exaltation of Jesus to be made equal
with the father.
Yeah,
that's what started it. This is prior to
the creation of earth, sir.
Right. Right. That Yes. And that and
so don't point to
So don't point to say, "Well, the
ascension
that we're not talking about his
exaltation as a man after incarnate."
No, we don't.
You changed the timeline that you you
said
after after his resurrection, he ex he
was exalted to heaven.
After he's incarnated as a man, he's
exalted because that was part of his
rightful rule and reign as a man. after
incarnating, not ontologically in his
being, he was fully divine, already
equal with the father. Don't give me
that when you guys try and do this of
like, well, see, there's the word
exaltation, so therefore you've just
shifted the timeline. No. Okay. So,
Jesus wasn't exalted then as a as a man
after his ascension. He was exalted
before then, but then incarnated and was
exalted again. You guys have two
exaltations.
Sure.
Is that what you're saying?
Jesus has two comingings. The first
coming and the second coming.
Yeah. You guys actually teach the third
coming. You guys actually teach the
third coming.
He can't.
You don't teach
You don't teach the second coming. You
No, I don't. You guys teach a third
coming, sir.
Second coming.
I I I We are so alike. And um that's
Yeah, we're we're not we're not alike.
We're definitely No, no, no. We're We're
not alike.
Um do not say that. Do not say that I'm
believing the same thing you are. We are
100% not believing the same thing. And
I'm going to bring you up the quote
right now. And I want you to show me
this from scripture and I want you to
defend this. Okay? We're going to look
at multiple quotes here. We're going to
look at multiple
I've been I've been nothing but
scripture with you. Scripture.
Scripture. Scripture.
Yeah. Yeah. And and your church. I don't
care about your own personal opinion.
The title of tonight is the SDA church.
Ellen White's writings speak with
prophetic authority and correct
inaccurate interpretations of scripture.
The great controversy theme is 100%
official SDA teaching. Don't play this
game. Don't do the pious. I've just
tried to stay with the Bible. No, no,
no. We're not playing that game. We're
not doing that. Okay.
A doctrine by scripture. I understand.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, this is also part of
your doctrine. And I need you to show me
this from scripture. Okay. So, real
quick here, let me switch tabs.
God is the God is the father of Christ.
Christ is the son of God. To Christ has
been given an exalted position. He has
been made equal with the father. All the
councils of God are open to his son.
This is prior to the incarnation, sir.
Wait, wait. What does it say prior to
the incarnation, by the way?
That's where it's at in the timeline.
Okay. If you're really going to play
that game, we'll just again go to the
next quote. Okay.
Please. Yeah.
And we're going to we'll look at it
systematically. I'll bring them all up
on here. Okay.
This is the f the the talking about the
first advent as you can see at the top.
The son of God was next in authority to
the great lawgiver.
He knew that his life alone could be
sufficient to ransom fall on man. He was
as of much more value than man as his
noble spotless character and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
hosts were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father not
in features alone but in perfection of
character.
Perfection of character.
Again this is again this is prior to the
creation of the earth. Now we'll go to
the fountain head statement. No, you you
uh like typical you focused on a part of
the statement that wasn't even in
question.
I could bold the stuff on the screen to
show the problem. I would, but I can't.
Here's your pre here's your pre-creation
narrative. The great creator assembled
the heavenly host that he might in the
presence of all the angels confer
special honor upon his son. The son was
seated on the throne with the father and
the heavenly throne of holy angels was
gathered around them. The father then
made known that it was ordained by
himself that Christ his son should be
equal with himself. So that wherever was
the presence of his son, it was as his
own presence. The word of the son was to
be obeyed as readily as the word of the
father. His son he had invested with
authority to command the heavenly host.
Especially was his son to work in union
with himself in the anticipated creation
of the earth and every living thing that
should exist upon the earth. His son
would carry out his will and his
purposes, but would do nothing of
himself alone. The father's will would
be fulfilled in him. She taught that
Jesus ontologically
not as after a man as incarnating which
is a totally different context because
even in the incarnation if you don't
understand the hypothetic union and the
communicato idiomatum the bond between
the divine and human natures and that
the man Christ Jesus being exalted is
not him ontologically receiving the same
level of authority and equality with God
the father in his being. He is eternally
co-equal with the father. He's the
almighty God. Do you agree that Jesus
Christ is the Lord God Almighty?
Of course, he is the God Almighty. But
you but the Trinity shows that there's
God the Father and God the Son that um
you're using the word ontologically. Um
and we're talking I don't want to get
into that grammar. I don't want this to
be semantics. I have two Bible passages
that support this view from Paul himself
and from the mouth of Peter himself that
they both agreed with this
um exaltation theology. This is called
the exaltation theology.
Um that that's what I'm going to call
it. Exaltation theology.
Um
okay, first Peter,
let's hear it.
He he met Jesus. Acts 2:36.
Acts 2:36. Dude, this has nothing to do
with precation earth and Jesus being
made equal with the father in in his
essence.
I'm I'm
that's what's happening.
Wait, I promise I'm going to get there
quickly. Acts 2:36, Peter said of Jesus,
I already know what it says. Yeah, I
know what it says.
That was very God has made him both Lord
and Christ. This Jesus whom you
crucified. So Jesus was
the man the man Christ Jesus
authority he was made Lord
by by God. He was
as a man as a man. This is him as a man.
You're adding that to the
No, I'm not. Whom was crucified? You
think God was you think the divine
nature is what is crucified?
Jesus is God.
Jesus was crucified. Therefore God in
the form of the son God was crucified.
See, you guys don't even have a basic
understanding of of fundamental
christologology because you're confusing
what's being said here with what is
being said by Ellen White. This is
fundamentally a category error. We can
deduce that it's as a man because whom
you crucified in the flow of what Peter
is talking about here as well is his
essential sermon causing the telling the
Jews who crucified Christ they needed to
repent because of who Christ was etc.
Nothing in there says anything about
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father. You just said that he's
the almighty. How is the Almighty
exalted to be made equal with the
almighty?
That is Jesus is a man. No, that's
because Paul is speaking about the
incarnation. He's talking about Jesus as
a man, his human nature. He's not
talking about ontologically prior to the
incarnation. The same Paul that says in
Colossians 2:9 he's the fullness of the
Godhead bodily is saying that Jesus was
given that
right
the same Jesus. Okay. Okay. You want to
go with the passage? I'll show
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on.
Okay.
Get your Bible. Get your Bible. Do you
have your Bible?
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Get Get your Bible out and go to
Isaiah 44. Okay.
I'm on it.
Okay. Let me know when you get there.
I'm here. I'm here.
Okay. Go. Isaiah 44.
Yeah. I'm an Adventist because I'm a
Bibleist. I'm already here.
Okay. Go to Isaiah 44:24.
Right there. Okay.
Read it.
Thus says the Lord, your redeemer, who
formed you from the womb. I am the Lord
who made all things, who alone stretched
out the heavens, who spread out the
earth by himself.
Okay. So, what does it say there?
I am the Lord who made all things who
alone who stretched out the heavens.
Okay. So, who's the Lord there? What's
the word Lord that's being translated?
Yahweh.
Correct. Go to Colossians 1.
Okay. Colossians 1.
What verse?
16.
Okay.
What does it say? For in him all things
were created, things in heaven and on
earth, visible and invisible, whether
thrones or powers or religious or
authorities, all things have been
created through him and for him.
So Yahweh alone created all things, but
Jesus created all things. So Jesus is
Yahweh, right?
Of course.
How was Yahweh exalted to be made equal
with Yahweh?
This is prior to the incarnation, sir.
You don't have the you can't point to
somewhere where it's talking about him
as a man to then read back into and say,
"Well, you're just shifting the
timeline." No, you're talking about
something fundamentally different. He's
Yahweh. Go back to N. Go back. Yep.
We'll we'll we'll call We'll bring that
up in a moment. But first, go back to
Isaiah. Okay.
Yep.
Go to Isaiah. Isaiah 43.
Oh, okay. Um, what I did was Okay.
Instead of backspacing, I'm going to
open another tab for that.
Okay. Go to Isaiah 43.
Oh, okay. Okay. So, let so I can have
them both out simultaneously. One
second, please.
I can't spell y'all.
It's getting late.
Yeah.
Okay.
What's your time zone?
Read versus central. Read verses 10
through Read verses 10 through 11.
Isaiah 44.
Okay. Isaiah 44 10-11.
Yep. And what does it say? Who fashions
a god or cast an idol that is profitable
for nothing? Behold, all his companions
are
No, no, no, no.
Isaiah 44.
Isaiah No. Isaiah 43:10 through 11.
Oh, 43.
It's on screen. It's on screen.
Isaiah 44. Oh,
no. 43. It's on screen.
Okay. 10 11.
10-11. You are my witnesses, declares
the Lord, and my servant whom I have
chosen, that you may know and believe
me, and understand that I am he. Before
me no god was formed nor shall there be
any after me.
And verse 11 I I am the Lord and beside
me there is no savior. Okay. So Jesus
explicitly states that he is or
scripture explicitly states that Jesus
is the savior. Where we previously were
in Isaiah 44. It says thus said the Lord
the king of Israel and his redeemer the
lord of hosts. I am the first. I am the
last. Beside me there is no god. So it
parallels here. There is no god beside
Yahweh. Well, Jesus explicitly states
that he's the first and the last, the
Almighty. Revelation 1:8 as well as 17 1
17-8 and Revelation 2:8. And Titus 2:13
says Jesus is our great God and savior.
If Yahweh alone is the first and the
last, the only savior, that means Jesus
is the Almighty. How is Jesus the
Almighty exalted to be made equal with
the father? He hasn't incarnated yet.
Explain that for us.
Okay. From the mouth of Paul. Um,
okay.
From the mouth of Paul.
You're going to use heresy 2 6 through8.
Right.
You just did a video on this last week.
Did you watch the video?
I watch
about how in the form of Jesus being in
the form of God. Well, I would like to
try to explain it first and I'll give
Jesus was in the form of God but did not
count equality with God something to be
grasped. So Jesus did not have full
equality with God being in the form of
God. So he was in the form of God but he
did not have full equality with God in
verse six and in verse seven. Um
I'm sorry.
Yeah, that's right. He did not grasp for
it even though he had the form of God.
did not fully grasp it. So this was be
clearly before he he the incarnation
and was not fully equal 100% and it's
not something he grasped but he was he
he received it after his resurrection
according to Peter. So once we put these
together Paul and Peter you you see how
that works and Ellen White expands upon
it.
Well let's go to Peter after this. First
let's let's drill this down. Okay.
Well same verse. It's not going to
Peter. It's the same verse. Acts 236.
I'm not going to another verse. It's
Oh, sorry. Gotcha. Okay. Well, you have
two totally different contexts, my
friend. In Acts chapter 2, that is not
what Paul or that's not Paul is not
saying the same thing here that Peter is
saying in Acts chapter 2. This is again
the issue with proof texting. What is
the context? Don't don't cheat and go
look at the heading. What is Paul
talking about here in in in Philippians
2? What's the context? The overarching
context. Why is Paul saying these
things? You think he's telling you that
Jesus was ontologically like in his
nature, his essence, whatever word you
want to use as a as a his existence, he
was not equal with the father, but was
made equal with the father by setting
his divine nature aside. You think
that's what what Paul's getting here?
Not not not those words, not not the
words that you used. He was in the form
of God but then not count equality with
God something that that he would grasp
that he would attain. So Paul had a very
a similar view as Ellen what Ellen White
is getting at because okay how can he be
in the form of God but
does not count equality with God
something to be grasped.
You need to watch the video I did last
week.
This is so pre-trinitarian
that yes Jesus is fully God. He is in
the form of God, but he's not fully
equal with God 100% until you just said
that he was Yahweh. You already admitted
he,
my friend, he created
He created all things. He's Yahweh.
Yes. Amen. Colossians 1. He created all
things. He was in the form of God. He
My friend,
yeah. Go ahead.
Okay. You You gave your explanation, so
I'm I'm gonna respond. You don't know
the context of this passage. Paul is
quoting this and I wish you would have
watched the full video. It wasn't very
long. Watch part five, folks, of the
Adventist Jesus series. I just uploaded
it last Monday. Go watch it. We went
over this. You are espousing what is
called the kotic heresy, the kosis
theory. This is an 18th century novelty
that your prophetist latched on to like
she did so many other things. The
context of this passage is not about
Jesus's ontos, his being, his nature,
his essence. Paul is talking about
humility.
He's giving an example and telling us
that we need to do the same thing that
Christ is doing. That's why he's
mentioning it. Are we supposed to empty
oursel of our divine attributes? No.
The grammar and the context of the
passage is speaking to Christ's function
as the divine savior, not to him
shedding himself of his divinity and
setting it aside. Christ added unto
himself a human nature while retaining
his true divinity, 100% man, 100% God.
Here, I'm going to read you a quote from
a commentary on this
quote. He's said to have emptied himself
in no other way than by taking the form
of a servant, not by losing the form of
God. For that nature by which he is
equal to the father. This is on verse 7.
It's a commentary on verse 7.
He is said to have emptied himself in no
other way than by taking the form of a
servant, not by losing the form of God.
For that nature by which he is equal to
the father in the form of God remained
immutable while he took our mutable
nature through which he was born of the
virgin. He did not take on his humanity
in the simple way that a person puts on
clothes as something exterior to him.
Rather, he took on human form in a
manner inexpressibly more excellent and
more intimate than that. The apostle has
made it sufficiently clear what he
meant. He was made to appear in human
likeness. He was not exhaustively
reduced to being a man. He rather
assumed the true human estate when he
put on the man. Close quote. That's
what's being said here is that Jesus
took the form of a slave in the likeness
of a man, but in doing so, he was still
superior to all of the creation. He's
the God man. He didn't discard himself
of his divine nature, setting it aside
for a period to res to reassume it
later, which in your guys' system, he
didn't even gain all of it back. He's
not omnipresent. He's omnipresent now
through the ministry of the Holy Spirit.
But along with theologians and
commentators down through the centuries,
they've all properly consistently
recognized the point that Paul is
making. So this ain't my private
interpretation.
It's not my own understanding. That's
not what's being said. Let's read.
Paul is exhorting us to follow the
example of Christ.
So if there is any encouragement in
Christ, any comfort from love, any
participation in the spirit, any
affection and sympathy, complete my joy
by being in the of the same mind, having
the same love, being in full accordion
of one mind. Do nothing from selfish
ambition. He's giving us exhortations on
how to act as believers. Let each of you
look not only to his own interest, but
also to the interest of others, having
this mind among yourselves, which is
yours in Christ Jesus. There's a phrase
of union with Christ as well, by the
way, folks. who though he was in the
form of God did not count his equality
with God a thing to be grasped but
emptied himself so he's talking about
how how Jesus even though he was equal
with the father he did not have to
incarnate he was not required to do that
so to speak he humbled himself though by
doing it he's now pointing to Jesus as
an example so while he even though he
was equal with God and he didn't
consider that something to be grasped
that would be he didn't consider that
something to be uh hotty about or
something to um keep him from being
above others. He humbled himself
but he emptied himself by taking the
form of a servant of his rightful estate
and abode. The the the word emptied
himself there is kino ke n o. That's the
Greek transliteration of the word.
That's where you get the kosis heresy
because it's that phrase. He emptied
himself. And how? Well, the commentary I
just read explains what he's the apostle
saying. By taking the form of a servant,
by being born in the likeness of men and
being found in human form, he humbled
himself by becoming obedient to the
point of death, even death on a cross.
Therefore, so because of that, God has
highly exalted him and bestowed on him
the name that is above every name. I
agree in the incarnation, Christ as a
man was exalted above all the creation.
That's nothing about his ontological
divinity as the divine logos, the second
person of the godhead. So that at the
name of Jesus, every knee will bow in
heaven and on earth and under and under
the earth and every tongue confess that
Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of God
the father. Paul is giving us
instruction using Jesus as an example to
humble ourselves and serve one another.
He's not talking about anything to do
with the actual nature of Jesus and him
emptying himself of being divine, only
being a man on earth. Because the issues
you're going to run into with that is
the fact that in scripture, all
throughout the New Testament, divine
attributes are ascribed to the person of
Jesus.
If he was only a man who emptied himself
on earth and then after resurrecting
assumed the divinity back on, you
shouldn't be able to ascribe divine
attributes to him while he's a man on
earth. I listed off a number of those in
the video, but there's far more. So,
this doesn't support that prior to the
creation of the earth, God the Father
exalted Jesus to be made equal with
himself, giving him authority that he
didn't previously possess. When you said
earlier, Jesus created all things and
he's Yahweh.
Nor does Peter. Acts chapter 2, nothing
to do with that. He's talking about
Jesus Christ, the man, because he's
preaching to people, letting them know
the man you crucified, that Christ
Jesus, he is the Messiah. He's going to
come back and judge you one day. So
repent and believe the gospel. It's
nothing about the nature of Jesus. You
guys have to start looking at scripture
in context. You said earlier, I'm an
Adventist. We're Bible. We're biblicist.
We're Bible. Well, you need to start
looking at the Bible in context, my
friend. Because the problem with all the
passages you've cited tonight are single
verses where you are reading into those
things a bunch of stuff that is not in
view.
It's not in view. The rich young ruler
is not a sotiological example. Again, go
and read the parallel. We need to get
off here. It's been three hours and 20
minutes. I did not want to go as long as
as last time, but we had to cover the
stuff we did. I wanted to engage with
some of you guys. But you need to go
look at the parallel of that, my friend.
You need to go look at where Jesus says
that the
the purpose of the rich and ruler. Go
read the parallel folks. I don't want to
get into all this because I'm going to
be here for another 25 minutes. Go look
at the parallel and you'll see it is not
a sotiological passage. He mentions
nothing about faith.
That's your key indicator there.
Something else is going on. Jesus was
making a broader point to an individual
explaining to him something. So if you
think that oh because he mentioned
eternal life okay so yeah you don't have
to have faith then but your guys's whole
system is predicated on faith in the
merits of Christ making the lawkeeping
acceptable okay anyways folks adventists
that came on thank you for those that we
weren't able to get to I apologize I'm
sorry um but we do need to cut it off
it's been 3 hours and 20 minutes this
will not be the last one of these by any
means um we'll do more of these you guys
are welcome to come back those of you
that want to come advent um
I I understand you guys are passionate.
I appreciate that. I'm passionate as
well, as you heard, as you saw. Um, but
you're not going to be able to
demonstrate to us that what the apostles
gave is the everlasting gospel of the
Adventist Church when your own sources
are saying it's a present truth message
and your prophetus is saying it's the
most important message for right now.
Trying to do these sorts of things like,
well, it's people are accountable to the
light that they're given. So, um, you
know, well, uh, no, it's not the gospel.
That's the point. The gospel is a simple
message. If you don't have the gospel
correctly, you're going to have all
sorts of issues downstream, which is
exactly what happens in the Adventist
church. You can say all this, you know,
well, it's the love of God, and
understanding the love of God will cause
you to grow in your understanding. And
no, folks, I believe the same gospel I
believed right after leaving Adventism.
I didn't know anything about systems of
theology. I didn't know anything about I
wasn't reformed. I wasn't a I I didn't I
was I would have been a standard fair uh
you know just sort of like
non-denomgoing
kind of like probably a provisionist if
we're using those sorts of terms or like
an Armenian or whatever. It has that has
nothing to do with the gospel. This idea
that oh if we refute re reform theology
that therefore vindicates Adventism. No,
not even close. All the people that
watch this this channel that are united
in one mind around the same gospel that
I am standing on that are not reformed,
they all want to have a discussion with
you. None of them agree with you guys
that that's just the logical I've heard
that from a number of people at pastors.
It's just the consistent Armenian
position to be what we believe. Yeah.
No, folks, this is not the gospel. None
of this is a part of the gospel. The
gospel is the good news of salvation in
the person and work of Jesus Christ and
what all that brings, which is about
being in union with Christ. You don't
have to believe any of this stuff on
here to be in union with Christ. You may
believe these things theologically. God
bless you if you do. Um, if you think
that there's some sort of salvific
thing, well, then shame on you. You need
to actually understand how you're
actually made right with God, which is
what I've been trying to hammer out
between last week and this week. Um,
union with Christ and these sorts of
things and the benefits that come with
that. the Adventist health message, the
seventh day Sabbath observant, none of
that is about salvation. You've made
that salvation. And so, it's so
intertwined in the Adventist system that
it's hard to see the separation. Um, but
that's not the gospel. That guy earlier,
he said that I was cherry-picking, you
know, or you used the same verses. Dude,
if you go on my channel and start back
at the beginning of my videos, my
friend, I'm not using the same proof
text like you guys do. Give me a break.
Give me a break. I'm quoting scripture
all over the place. We could sit here
and just go through the the proofs that
I would present for the who Jesus is as
the Almighty. You can look this up at
yourselves, by the way, folks. Literally
go to the Answering Adventism website.
You want to see the the proof on this?
Are these all the same verses that I'm
always using, my man? Oh, sorry. Wrong
thing there.
Always using the same verses, huh?
Oh, what do you know? By both by way of
both Ellen G. White and the SDA Bible
commentary volume 5, page 1129 in Advent
theology, Jesus isn't the almighty God.
He tried to say that they were, but no,
Ellen White said that he's not. Only the
father is consistent with their teaching
of the Kosis heresy. Now, they'll point
to the quotes and say, well, no, she
over here says this and used that
defense that Philippians 2 6 through8
says that Jesus set his divine nature
aside. That takes you to I showed this
in the video, a page on here where they
try and state that they affirm the
hypothatic union.
Oh, where's it at?
Well, it's in that video if you guys
want to go check that out. But
nevertheless, that's why I brought up
this tab. There's all the stuff. It's
all hyperl. You can go through this
whole thing. Adventist apologists have
tried a plethora of defenses for her
statement where she says that uh Jesus
is not the Lord God Almighty. Here's the
different defenses that they give with
links to all this stuff. If they say
this, here's what they don't understand.
There's some that say she's right. He's
not the Almighty. Only the Father's the
Almighty.
She's differentiating between the Jesus
and the Father when she said this again.
Then showing where Ellen White.info
asserts this defense and falsely makes
the claim that Christians believe God is
three distinct beings just like they do.
Um and just a whole host of things. Then
the biblical evidence. Where have I
quoted, sir, the guy that was on here
earlier, where did I quote any of this
stuff previously on this channel?
Deuteronomy 6:4, Ephesians 4:5, Romans
10:9, Revelation 19:60. Bro, on my
website, I'm quoting scripture all over
the place. The idea that I'm always just
quoting the same passages, that is not
true. Go through this, folks. You see
for yourself. I mean, I had to stop at a
certain point because there was so much.
I have more to add to this page. But
that alone, I'm quoting from all over
the Bible. So don't use this nonsense
that you're just quoting all the same
verses as well. No, man. I can show you
the gospel in the Old Testament just
like Paul does when he when he appeals
to Abraham and shows the gospel of
salvation by grace alone through faith
alone in the in the one true God alone.
I can do it exclusively from the Old
Testament. Bring out your sword and
let's do it. Because if that was your
defense, my friend, you seem like a nice
guy. You've called him both times now
and you're welcome to obviously always
call back and have a have a good back
and forth. But if that's your defense,
well, Jesus said to the rich young
ruler, "Keep the law and you'll get
eternal life."
Yeah, that while that may you may think
that that's helping your guys' teaching
of the law. I appreciate you admitting
that you guys think that lawkeeping is
is in aid to to what saves you, that
doesn't vindicate any of this,
that this stuff is the everlasting
gospel. We heard nothing about the
everlasting gospel being a different the
same message as the gospel because just
like their scholars say the gospel is a
limited gospel. They have the fullness
of the gospel. So Adventists the mind is
not changed. The ma the mind is not
changed. And so we want you to come know
the truth. We want you to come know the
true Christ, his gospel. We're going to
keep doing these. We'll do variety of
topics. So, those of you that are
chomping at the bit to talk about other
topics outside of this, it's very hard
for me, honestly, to have discussions
with Adventists on any other topics like
the law of God when the God you're
talking about is a different God. It's
hard to talk about any of these other
things that are downstream of the core
foundational thing that's like
Christianity 101. To go talk about what
they always want to talk about,
esquetology, that's like Christianity
401, and you're trying to skip past all
these other places you haven't even
passed to have discussions about those
things. But nevertheless, this will not
be the only topic of these streams. Yes,
we'll be getting into the Sabbath. Yes,
we'll be getting into all sorts of other
things. We're going to keep doing
streams like this. But Adventists, it's
time to get serious about this. It's
time to consider these things. Um
because this church is not teaching the
gospel that was revealed by Jesus Christ
to the apostles that has been handed
down to us today. You saw the sources
yourself. Anybody wants these resources,
they are all over answering
adventism.com. Just go on there and type
in everlasting gospel up in the search
bar and see all the options that point
down. There's video, there's written
articles that have all of the sources
linked to official Adventist source
materials. And by official, I mean
authoritative figures, scholars, Ellen
White, the Pioneers, the Adventist
Church's website, the Adventist
Theological Society, the Adventist
Biblical Research Institute. I don't
know any higher authorities to be going
to than these sorts of things. So, you
go and you check those things out and
see this is not the same message, folks.
The gospel is a simple message. It's not
some crazy advanced. Yeah, it's deep.
It's deep. It moves a person. It change
the power of God to salvation. It
changes people. Of course, it's deep and
it's powerful. But that doesn't make it
something that well, as you grow in your
understanding, you learn that it has new
facets. And no, that that that's not how
that works. You're trying to port your
system of theology over top of the
gospel through means of the great
controversy theme and then make that
whole thing the package of salvation.
Because at the end of the day, that is
how you're saved. As we saw in the
previous quotes, it's your obedience not
just to the Ten Commandments. It's
really your obedience to this system
because what Ellen White was giving is
prophetic authority and is binding on
you. It's coming from the throne room of
God and you're going to be accountable
for the light that you've rejected.
Remember from the the funeral stream,
folks, we read like a two-page quote
where she says this is rejecting her
writings is the slide of people into
predition. It starts there and then
you'll eventually reject the Bible. So,
it's just crazy. the Adventist to to
hear these sorts of defenses when it it
just it doesn't it doesn't measure up.
Jesus is the Almighty, folks. If you
take problem with that, well, this
platform stands on the triune God. That
Jesus Christ, the Father, and the Spirit
are the one God Almighty. We will not
pivot off of that. I would die for the
triune God. I would die for his gospel.
Um, so we will not pivot off that. If
that's not, you know, your sort of cup
of tea, uh, you know, bless you, but
that's the platform we stand on. That is
the one true God. We will defend his
gospel. We will stand united with other
Christians who are united on that same
gospel and that same God. Um doesn't
mean I want to have conversations with
people who you know disagree on on those
sorts of matters. Um but as an
organization or platform, that is what
we stand on. That is the truth. I will
go down and my flag will be planted in
that. Um from you know the the day I was
changed by the triune God to the the the
last breath. That's the prayer. God keep
me in that truth. So, next week, Anthony
Rogers is going to be on a week from
tonight teaching on old covenant worship
versus new covenant worship. We're going
to be getting into the new creation
versus the old creation and why the
Jewish Sabbath, the old creation
memorial is gone, done away with. The
Adventist Church is memorializing their
old creation. They're event uh
essentially saying to the world that
that the the substance of the type in
the shadow hasn't come. The Messiah
hasn't come and redeemed the creation.
and and we're going to get into some of
that sort of that that sort of stuff
next week. He's going to predominantly
be the one doing the the teaching and
the talking because he's qualified to do
it. He did an excellent excellent 4-hour
presentation um some weeks ago. And so I
said, "Brother, you need to come to
Answering Adventism and give this same
sort of presentation because this is
just gold, scriptural gold." So, make
sure to tune in next week. Anthony
Rogers will be here to discuss Old
Covenant and New Covenant worship. With
that said, thank you guys so much for
being here. Long night, three and a half
hours, but it's been great. Especially
those of you who are here for the whole
thing. I appreciate you guys, especially
since you will sit here and listen to me
of all people, just some bumpkin who
loves theology, loves the Lord Jesus,
loves the triune God, loves his gospel,
wants to be obedient to that, and uh try
and reach as many people as possible.
Um, but as always, until next time, God
bless.
[Music]